this is jaco podcast number 92 with echo
Charles and me Jocko willing a good
evening echo good evening the concept of
finding an AED is relatively simple it
is essentially identifying what doesn't
belong in the natural area in front of
you before one proceeds however one must
ensure that all of the Marines with them
are at a safe distance such that if the
searcher unintentionally detonates an
AED during his investigation the Marines
he is with will not be harmed the first
step is to take a good look at where you
are and where you plan to go identify
anything that looks out of the ordinary
with respect to nature the world
naturally doesn't often have patterns or
perfect shapes essentially you are
looking for areas where you suspect a
man has been in contact with nature when
one patrols in the same area frequently
one can establish a baseline observation
for what to look for and what the area
looks like normally thus on subsequent
visits it is possible to identify
elements that are out of place the next
step is to investigate the route that
you have chosen through this danger area
the three main tools used for this
investigation are the eyeballs a metal
detector and a cutting-edge digging
device called the human hand proceeding
slowly in a forward direction one swings
the metal detector in a fashion that
covers every square inch of the chosen
route in order to do this start with a
metal detector to one side of the route
and move it straight across to the other
side keeping the search head an inch or
two above and parallel to the ground
once it is a cross moved the detector
forward half the length of the search
head and swing it in the opposite
direction to the original side of the
route this is a process that continues
for the entirety of your time moving
through the danger area at some point
during your movement along this route
you will want to investigate certain
spots that you think may contain an ie D
you can be alerted to these spots in
multiple ways from your early assessment
before proceeding through the area newly
acquired suspicions as you move through
the area and also from sounds that your
metal detector makes the process of
swinging the metal detector back and
forth and inching forward is
time-consuming the best of the best are
the ones that can optimize safety and
keep time spent to a minimum it is
always better however to err on the side
of caution except in the most extreme of
emergencies the investigation of a
suspicious area must proceed with
extreme caution
you start by kneeling down being sure to
be well balanced and stable you must
ensure that no gear is going to
accidentally fall off or slip out and
touch the ground you reach out with your
fingers and with the gentleness of a
butterfly landing on a daisy move the
dirt in front of the front edge of the
metal hit proceed forward a nano meter
at a time in this fashion uncovering
more dirt over a wider space until you
find either find the metal that set off
the detector or you are satisfied that
there is no danger from this particular
metal hit if metal is found the area
must be rechecked to ensure that the
metal was found was
a decoy one may think that the tension
during this time is akin to being Tom
Cruise dangling inches above a motion
sensor floor but the necessity of having
a clear mind and the amount of practice
that has gone into this exact process
makes it seem second nature and ordinary
after you are satisfied that you have
cleared this suspicious area proceed
forward as you move forward you are also
proofing the lane that thing proofing
the lane or confirming that is free from
IEDs is usually done with a special
mechanical device but it is now being
done with your feet and don't forget as
you go forward to lay down markers for
everyone else who comes behind you to
follow this is the way that I handled
the situation I was now in I inched
forward with my metal detector I didn't
see anything special about the area my
metal detector was making noises but
nothing large enough that I thought I
warranted an investigation the Marines
and our patrol watched and waited as I
cleared and proofed the lane
then it all went black
now that description is about as good as
I have read about the act of searching
for IEDs then I actually never searched
for IEDs in that type of method and of
course in Ramadi everyone was always
searching for IDs you're always looking
you're inspecting we were suspicious of
every pile of rubble every piece of junk
on the road every off-colored piece of
dirt or pavement or concrete or sand but
we were in the city and there was
pedestrian traffic and most of the IEDs
were targeting vehicles not foot patrols
but whether in a vehicle or on foot the
IE D for the most part has been the
biggest threat and the biggest cause of
casualties in our recent Wars and for
the enemy
it's a low-risk high-reward
weapon and for us
it's an evil weapon it's a cowardly
weapon and it is an effective weapon
it's a weapon the plants itself in your
mind always there waiting
around that corner under that curb on
the other side of that sidewalk it's
waiting
now there are those whose job it is to
actually interdict that weapon
the the ID it is their job to face that
fear up close and personal day in and
day out you've got a EOD explosive
Ordinance Disposal is one group that
does it
complete professionals and the EOD
technicians that I deployed within the
SEAL Teams were just outstanding and
everything that they did which by the
way was not only find and disarmed IDs
they also did everything that we did
they cleared rooms and patrolled through
the streets and maneuvered and fire
flights just as the seals did they were
awesome and in addition to a OD combat
engineers in the Army and the Marine
Corps also do mind clearance and of
course I talked about combat engineers a
lot because of the incredible role that
they played in the Battle of Ramadi and
the combat engineers were outstanding in
their standard job of building combat
outposts and building and maintaining
the the infrastructure of the bases and
they were they were awesome in that
performance under fire but at some point
the combat engineers job morphed into
mine clearance and it's because I would
suspect you know they work with
demolitions so so combat engineers do
breaches to doors and to walls they
build bridge roads and bridges and they
also clear obstacles from roads and
bridges and so eventually at some point
this morphed into combat engineers doing
AED clearance both on roads
and then out on foot patrols now there's
jobs in the world that I wouldn't want
to do and this is one of them it takes a
massive amount of patience it takes an
incredible amount of skill and it takes
an incredible ability to overcome fear -
if you're gonna actually seek out and
touch the thing the very thing that is
trying to kill you in order to stop it
that's a job that I didn't want then and
I don't want now and I am thankful that
there was others that stepped up and did
that job and I'm honored to have on the
podcasts tonight one of those brave men
a Marine Corps combat engineer who
served in Iraq and in Afghanistan and
the guy by the way who wrote that
opening description of what it was like
to go out and hunt for IEDs a guy by the
name of mr. Rob Jones Rob welcome to the
show this isn't this is an honor for me
to be I just really appreciate
appreciate you giving me the opportunity
to to come on the show oh man trust me
the honors all all our thousand percent
you can't even argue with that won't let
it happen
give us just before we jump into your
Marine Corps career just give us a
little pre Marine Corps background on
growing up and what that where that was
and what it was like can I answer your
question about how combat engineers came
to find IEDs yeah please do so when you
go to combat engineer school one of the
things they teach you is minefield and
placement and defeat and to do that you
use mine detectors and metal detectors
so I think that's the main reason that
it
I wonder at what point would you think
that came from World War two I don't
know that's a good question is yeah when
I said it morphed into I was thinking
like back yeah you know must have been
some time in World War two where they
said you know okay we're gonna get over
this river okay so a common engineer is
gonna get over the river we're gonna
secure this compound okay we're gonna
secure the compound or we're gonna
rebuild this compound okay well at some
point they said you know what what if
there's mines there okay well we got to
get them cleared out yeah so at some
point they realized that you can't build
if you can't clear right yeah and you
can't move if you can't clear so I just
got to do it yeah somebody's got to do
it and and they weren't able to slough
off that job onto somebody else which is
what I would have been trying to do
which is what I would have been
absolutely been trying to do like hey
can we get somebody else to do that job
yeah so that's good
so how'd you end up in the Marine Corps
oh yeah my background I grew up in a
farm nothing really special about my
upbringing decided form it was a horse
farm I hated horses because I had to
pick up this way to say what is what do
you do what is the purpose of a horse
farm though the farm that I grew up on
the purpose of it was my parents would
take people on horseback riding trips
okay they would pay them money and
they'd take him out for a couple hours
in the forest got it got it and so was
my duty to clean up after the horses
feed the horses stack their hay bales in
the summertime get them their water so I
didn't really enjoy the horses as much
as most people would but you know I'm
thankful that I had that experience
because I think it did instill in me a
work ethic that doesn't that a lot of
people don't get yeah so I I think when
you come from because you know a lot of
guys when they come in the military they
they've never worked hard before but the
guys I've met the military that came
from some kind of a farming background
they're like hey yeah I'm so happy here
I'm not up at 3 o'clock in the morning
you know milking cows or whatever or
cleaning up horse shit in your case the
number
I had to wield this wheelbarrow full of
manure up a fence board onto this big
pile and sometimes I fell off that thing
every time with this curse those words
as I hate it now I like horses fines I
don't know you've gotten over your horse
PTSD it's so something what you you you
graduated from high school and then you
went to college right yeah I went to
Virginia Tech I was actually a computer
science major
I'm already suspect that goes impressed
I'm suspect and so at some point during
that during my college career my
sophomore year I decided that computer
science was not for me how do you feel
now that's right betrayed and I decided
I don't know I felt like I had spent the
first 20 years of my life kind of
looking after myself and now I needed to
do something that was beyond my own
self-interest and a buddy of mine of
just doing the Marine Corps so I read a
couple books about the Marine Corps
Brotherhood of heroes about the Battle
of Pele Lou mm-hm and I said yep that's
what I want to do I want to join the
Marine Corps so before telling my
parents before telling anybody looked up
where the recruiter was went down there
he wasn't there
Marine Corps recruiter wasn't there Air
Force recruiter tells me to come in his
office and tells me about the Air Force
and I said yeah just tell me when the
Marine Corps back yeah nothing against
the Air Force but I had already decided
on yeah Marine Corps yeah and so I I
joined up and I think it's I this may be
right or wrong I'm pretty sure it's
right the Marine Corps has like the
lowest recruiting budget and they have
the highest recruiting numbers because
it's the Marine Corps yeah it's just
there their approach I guess yeah like
oh you want to be one of us right maybe
yeah see you again yeah good luck yeah
so I joined up as a reservist my
original plan cuz I was after my junior
year so I wanted to finish college at
least
so my original plan was I did the 92 day
reservist program where I went to boot
camp after my junior year then I
finished my last year of college and
then I went to job school and MCT how
did your academic performance change or
did it between pre boot camp and post
boot camp
it didn't a whole lot because I think I
kind of checked out of college after my
junior year I was like I just want to go
deploy but I just kind of want to get
this degree done mmm I just so I have it
now after I deployed a few a couple
times and had a little bit more life
experience to probably a lot different
but just those three months at boot camp
didn't really change my your academic
approach I was plenty smart I was smart
enough I just didn't care that much
about it anymore
yeah so my original plan was to do that
and then have the little bit of
experience as an enlisted guy and then
use my degree to become an officer but
when I was in engineer school after that
that second summer my company my reserve
company said were send to volunteer
platoon to Iraq so I said well that's
the whole reason I joined up was to go
fight the war so screw being an officer
I'm gonna deploy and so then we go to my
first deployment so I thought it was
pretty you got a good note in here about
about the Marine Corps and I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna read this I'm
taking this stuff from your journal that
you have online which is awesome read so
here we go back to the journal the
Marine Corps began to shape me long
before I ever ever arrived at boot camp
in Parris Island South Carolina Carolina
it started when I read the book
Brotherhood of Heroes the tale of the
Battle of tellou in world war ii it was
through the stories of them of the
Marines told in those pages that I was
introduced to the courage spirit
tenacity altruism and brotherhood that
the Marines possess qualities that I
would soon be ingrained with as
well the basics of these qualities were
taught to me and my fellow recruits in
boot camp through rudimentary but
effective means the proverbial stick it
was through punishment that we were
shown what it meant to possess the
attributes of a Marine punishment would
come in a variety of modes based on the
same concept
countless push-ups sit-ups sprinting
carrying and of course screaming the
drill instructors would use any excuse
not that they needed one to inflict pain
upon us not being loud enough looking in
the wrong place in perfection and
uniform dirty squad Bay and not moving
fast enough for their inspections to
name a few the reality of the situation
was that we were never loud enough
always looking in the wrong place never
had perfect uniforms the squad bay was
always too dirty and we were simply too
slow the idea wasn't simply to
pointlessly inflict pain but to teach
lessons using the pain as the instructor
it was to force us to make ourselves
better so the whole platoon as a whole
would be better the idea was to form a
brotherhood through shared suffering and
shared dependence it was to teach us to
keep fighting the pain so that the
platoon as a whole could stop being
punished the point was that once we
reached perfection the requirements
changed so that we were forced to
constantly reach for it thus forcing us
to become better than we ever knew we
could be this is how the Marine Corps
takes hunks of iron and turns them into
jewels steel
that's why the Marine Corps doesn't need
a lot of recruit and money but so true
and I like that I liked what you pointed
out the shared dependence and how when
you're going through boot camp scenarios
and training scenarios that are really
hard you realize you're not gonna be
able to do this alone and you're gonna
have to rely on these other guys who you
may not in the civilian world you
wouldn't have even been associated with
and now you're not only associated with
them you depend on them for for your
survival and to get through it and
that's I think that's what makes that's
what makes that military experience and
certainly the Marine Corps does an
outstanding job of it of formulating
that bond that is is unique to the
military yeah that's what that's the
thing that makes Marines what they are
and brings out the best in people's when
they're doing something not for their
own self-interest but for somebody else
and I would volunteer for the worse
stuff so that I could prevent my buddies
from having to do it like walking
through the Euphrates River looking for
whatever trying to find weapons caches
in Iraq and then getting back at the end
of the day just totally soaked and
covered in trash water you know and they
come in say we're doing it again who
wants to go I'm like yeah I'll go go
again you know and that's I think that's
why I really I kind of enjoyed the
combat engineer role up to because I'm
going out there protecting people
protecting my buddies protecting other
Marines and taking the risk on me and I
mean that's what being a Marine is all
about anybody else would have done it
too and so you go your first deployment
to Iraq and what was that deployment
like where'd you go uh Hibernia over an
army and what yeah so this is 2008 so mm
these are pretty mellow at 2008 yeah
my racket kind of slowed down at that
point wasn't much going on we had one
tiny little incident where we were on a
convoy and some guy knows were fired
maybe three a K rounds and then ran away
it was so you know at nothing and now
but that wasn't like the first couple
weeks really what was your response to
the three rounds from an ak-47
I continued sitting in the back of the
seventh on did I did like an
eighteen-year-old Lance Corporal unload
with 700 rounds of 50 Cal or no it was a
long convoy so it was way up there and I
was like oh I gotta get out
I gotta get up there but it was it was
over before it was done when she could
they shoot back to they return fire at
him no I don't think so I mean he like
he did one of those things we raised
over and then left by the time anybody
was able to figure out where he was it's
gone so that was but that was in the
first couple weeks so you know kind of
off to a good start and then nothing
else happened really so what were you
guys doing during that deployment I
guess it was kind of the the build
portion okay of the strategy at that
point you know we were we were helping
the local population build up their
cities build we were helping to build
Iraqi police stations and but what I
spent most of my time doing was when we
would go out and find buried weapons
caches so just these old stores of RPGs
and stuff that the al Qaeda used to be
using right but they just left there and
then so the local population would sew
or somebody would give us a tip right
and we would go out to this big field
and they'd say yeah supposedly somewhere
in here there's a weapons cache so we
take out our metal detectors and sweep
every square inch of that field or Hill
or wherever we were tree tree line and
until we either just start to determine
those nothing or we would find it and
we'd dig it up and stack it and then he
OD
come and blow it up and were you
attached to a like an a combat engineer
platoon for were you attached to an
infantry platoon yes the way it works
for the what we call division side
engineers like common engineer battalion
is one combat engineer platoon is
attached to an infantry battalion and
then you kind of break it down so one
squad of that platoon goes with each
company on it and then one team goes
with the platoon so you kind of help
that platoon out you're just pretty much
attached to them the entire time so when
you guys would be doing these clearances
of lack of let's say a big field it
would be a platoon a marine corps
platoon and you would be doing all all
the sweeping yeah so it'd be a Marine
Corps platoon or a squad would used to
be a squad okay so it's a little squad
would uh we'd go out on a squad patrol
patrol out there they would set up
security on the area and they would just
wait there and then you be me and one
other guy and we would sweep and
sometimes we would have one of the
infantry guys have a etool mm-hmm like
dig there and you would dig and then
would you when you'd find caches would
you guys blow them in place or would you
recover it I guess it would depend we
would take pictures of what we found so
we could write the report when we got
back and if it was out in the middle of
nowhere a lot of the times they would
they'll blow it in place yeah we have to
wait for EOD they wouldn't let us do it
that's that's actually really jacked up
there's only one EOD unit for the for
EOD guys for the entire battalion and
not to mention that's the fun part
exactly right and I have I know they
used to back in like 2005 combat
engineers we're doing all that all the
time and just lay it out just
sympathetically detonate it with the
stick of c4 and that's all it is you
know what this is it's because the war
had slowed down yeah
that's an is only worse those down all
of a sudden people start putting the
rules and regulations and wait no we
could have you do that one is that same
thing we had the heaviest I'm sure when
you guys were in Ramadi he just had the
standard flak vest he had this
ridiculous
turtle shell fronts appease backs
appease side sapis neck protector groin
protector everything but protector like
it was just the the vest itself was 70
pounds let me tell you something
interesting about that when we were in
Ramadi not everyone had that and
everyone wanted it and they did their
best I remember actually the colonel the
brigade coming down and bringing side
sappy plates down to Combat Outpost to
hand him out to guys because everybody
wanted him they wanted the neck
protectors the shoulder protectors the
groin protectors they wanted everything
yeah I mean most many guys just hey you
know especially you're sitting in a
turret or yeah like load me up I want
all that the neck or they wanted it all
yeah because it was gnarly yeah and then
go try and do a hit on a house with it
ya know that part's not fun but so it's
probably that same thing where they're
just coming up with all the safety rules
and you have to have your helmet gloves
eye protection on at all times when
you're outside the wire so for whatever
reason they didn't let us blow it up so
we'd have to wait for EOD to come out
and then they would either blow it up
there if it was out in the middle of
nowhere but if it was in the city they
would usually take it somewhere and and
meanwhile the rest of the Combat
Engineer Battalion are out do helping
with the building the structures
building schools helping the
infrastructure and stuff like that it
would depend I mean yeah so whatever
that platoon that they were attached to
was doing they just be doing that and
then every now and then if they needed
all of us back to build up an Iraqi
police station they would call everybody
in or everybody but a couple guys in and
then we'd all go out as a platoon to
build that go out it but I spent most of
my time just doing the cash sweeping and
go on patrols so within the platoon or
certain people designated as like
minesweepers or does everyone get
trained everybody should be able to do
it got it how come you kept getting
though because you volunteered for that
you said hey I'll go find it yes I mean
and my fireteam was more my squad was
kind of
we didn't want to do the construction
stuff because we thought it was boring I
wasn't great at can strike I could swing
a hammer but you know I wasn't like good
at it and so we kind of tried to put
ourselves in positions where we wouldn't
have to go do that stuff we tried to
always be out with the but with the
squads with the platoons as often as we
could so we could avoid the construction
stuff but then yeah that's what I wanted
to be doing yeah yeah be out on patrol
yeah exactly so that so then that
deployment you come home and you had
already graduated from college at this
point right yeah and so you come home
and then what happens when you get home
so what's your plan when you get home
when I get home
well so we were in Iraq and my buddy
Ronny and Daniel we were all drinking
and we were like that was not what we
wanted you know what the good thing is
when you're drinking that's when you
make your best military decisions about
what to do with your career but yeah we
were sitting there going that was not
what we were hoping it would be we
wanted to do some fighting do some
killing so we were like we got to figure
out a way to go to Afghanistan and so we
started trying to look up because we
were in the reserves so sometimes
there's there's programs where you can
be in augmentee an individual augmentee
did you have a civilian job at this
point I didn't because I just graduated
college you just graduated college then
you go under ployment then you come home
and now you're saying alright what do
how do I get back how do i how do I go
fight I had 25,000 bucks from deployment
so I bought a motorcycle you know
another good investment good long-term
investor craft future yes I was looking
I was looking for a job to tide me over
and trying everything I could to go to
Afghanistan but luckily pretty shortly
after we got back we go to drill a
company says send volunteer platoon to
Afghanistan and boom right here because
that Afghanistan was heating up yeah if
you remember but but we had started to
wait about
eight or nine months before we went to
the workup for that so I just took a job
putting out traffic counters like
there's a little to go across the road
and you attached a little electronic box
to it so I just took a job doing that
that's sort of that related to IEDs
isn't it a little bit it's on the side
of the road then I just got in shape and
partied now did you did you do more
drill once you're getting ready to
deploy yeah well uh so when I say drill
I guess I should explain that's the the
deal for reservists you go in like one
weekend one weekend a month that's your
drill that's called the drill yeah do
they escalate that at all when you're
gonna deploy yes so they kind of they
kind of cater the drills that you do
based on what what she's gonna need
upcoming so I do recall we did a couple
where we would do go ago do uh like an
AED training section and then we would
since I had experience now we would just
take whenever we were at a drill we
would just start training the other new
guys that we're gonna be going with us
on machine guns metal detectors and just
train getting them trained up but yeah
and so a lot of the training was kind of
on our own because you only get that one
weekend a month and they only have so
much money and they have to train the
whole company as opposed to just the
platoon that's going right so so then
did they activate you how far before
deployment to the activate you see you
can do some like legitimate real
training we so we did we actually
managed to get a month at Camp Lejeune
at Courthouse Bay which is the combat
engineer school and so we did manage to
get a month-long school of you know just
doing demolition refreshment more IEDs
stuff patrol practice you know just
doing all sorts of training like that
and then your work up is pretty much
just however long it takes to do Mojave
Viper with your battalion
and then maybe a month before that yeah
so so maybe three months total before
you're going on yeah stack it all four
months got it
and were you when the rest of the guys
so it's one platoon that's going one
platoon one pussy wasn't even a full
between of those three squads okay so
how many guys that total it was actually
even short squats - so was let me think
eats those fire - 9 10 11 per squad yes
sir like 35 right then 3 for the brass
of the platoon so Jack then you go you
do your desert drill and everyone's
unified and then you leave before that
and then then you and then you go on
deployment yeah so they give you a
little bit of yeah they give you a
little bit of leave before you have to
go over so it's like four or five days
so everybody flies home and then God
comes back so now you show up in
Afghanistan and what's how's that
different from Iraq when you get there
you know what the first portion of it
was not that different the terrain was a
lot different mmm so where'd you where'd
you first go so in Afghanistan we were
we started I was I deployed with 3/7 as
an attachment 3rd battalion 7th Marines
Minh and we were in delle rom which I'm
pretty sure it was in Helmand province
so it was kind of right on the border so
I don't recall exactly but and pretty
much kilo company was the company that
my squad was attached to and they got
sent out just in the middle of nowhere
to a fob and then they had a patrol base
that was even smaller
you didn't even further out that I got
sent to I was a team leader mm-hmm and
so usually you would have one team in
the one spot and one team in the other
spot but since we were kind of short on
guys as pretty much I was the only
engineer for that platoon mhm and yes so
we were in in dela Rahm and so in
Hibernia was urban and everything was
really walking through a city everything
was urban but Afghanistan was just
Barun and what when you got out to this
forward base what were you do what were
you guys doing out there what was the
what was the infantry person that you
were attached to doing out there
patrolling so it was kind of similar
that's why I say it wasn't a whole lot
different from Iraq because we were
basically just interacting with the
local populace finding out what they
needed providing security for that area
like they had a bazaar that would come
every weekend so we go out provide
security for that and so I was still
using my metal detector to clear danger
areas if we can't there's a lot of
waters out there so we'd have to funnel
through the Wadi so I checked that how
often were you were you find in IEDs I'm
not sure I didn't find a one on there
now there was it was a pretty pacified
area I think we had one firefight that
one of the squads got into and that's it
so so your first part of the deployment
and how long was that how long was that
part of the deployment that was two and
a half three months I think so that's
kind of like a little tune-up right and
then we passed that area off to the
Georgian Army and that's when I move to
saying and to to take over from the
Brits and now sangan's and like that's
Helmand province central right that's
that's it yeah that's Taliban central
down there
yeah and as soon as you get on the
ground there did you feel it when you
got on the ground we knew yeah I mean we
kind of did a push into that area before
we actually moved out there and we knew
shit was getting real when we they just
they're like pack up a pack and we got
on the helicopter and they just flew us
out and just dropped us off in the
middle of absolutely nowhere and we just
started walking they just leave your
packs here and start walking that way
and just just basically just taking
territory from the Taliban now did you
guys do a thorough turnover with the
Brits I wasn't a part of that but
not I mean we we pretty much came into
fob Inkerman and were there for a day
day and a half and and the Brits were
gone no no we only came in and then yeah
and pushed out so the Brits were there
when you were when you were there on the
yeah we were both there at the same time
they're probably the headquarters
elements were doing a turnover yeah they
were like hey we're getting our boys on
yeah we started pushing immediately and
we had a couple World Marines with us
and some British Army or this I think
they had a small or maybe a tow that we
didn't have
so like units that we we needed from
them they would send out with us and
they were great but from what I
understood they just didn't have the
manpower to really do much were they the
guys that were with you we you would
they give you any turnover items like
hey you need to look out for this hey
this is what's going on here
I didn't receive any because I don't
think they really went out much so I
don't not really sure how much they
really could have told us and about what
was outside of the patrol bases and I
never I don't even remember I think we
may have talked to their combat
engineers we got some demo from them
like hey can we have some det-cord and
they gave it to us and that's about it
and that's because they were just
completely undermanned yeah but from
what I understand I mean I obviously I'm
not a part of the upper echelon out
there and stuff but I think that's the
reason they just they set up patrol base
and they had the patrol bases but they
pretty much just sat there and got
ambushed and got shot at every day and
didn't do a lot of patrolling so then
you guys roll in and the the like the
broad strategies you're gonna start
moving from patrol base you're gonna
push out take another compound secure it
and then operate out of there for a
while and then push push you on pretty
much just take the Taliban's territory
by going out clearing a compound and
that's what a major part of what I was
doing it on this push was clearing
compounds just in case there were
booby-trapped and then yeah we take over
that compound sandbag it up knock down
some trees and some explosives create
those fields of fire and then once I was
set up we start doing some patrols
security patrols and then
repeat and were you guys getting in
contact with the Taliban
yeah often they were pretty much
shooting at us most days more during us
most days not very accurate but yeah
they were shooting at us at least and we
when we would go out on patrols they'd
shoot at us but they're always shooting
from way far away and you know we'd
shoot back but it wasn't like further on
in the deployment when the corns when
the corn grew a lot taller I wasn't
there for it cuz I got hurt by them but
that was when they were like people were
shooting at each other in the cornfield
like five feet away mm-hmm so but but
while you were there it was more distant
really far distant contact yeah we were
you guys taking any casualties I think
not
not tons I mean obviously everyone is a
major major sacrifice but there was one
sniper that got killed on the initial
push on mousical ah before we even got
to singing and besides that I don't
remember
oh my buddy Ronnie got hit in the face
with a piece of RPG he didn't go home he
just had to go get it taken care of so
minor stuff like that but yeah that
minor stuff only happens when stuff is
going on yeah so and by the way that
little piece of shrapnel you know that
thing can kill you just as easily is uh
you know a full piece you're strapping
what is I yeah exactly
um but I would say so you're you're like
now every patrol that you guys are going
out is like hey now how often are you
finding IEDs at this point not tons
trying to think and every now and then
not very often I mean because the I
think the area that we were in initially
was still pretty close to the main fob
mhm and then as you went out there would
be just fields of them and the way that
we were getting out to
the the patrol bases where we were using
Mik licks and so that was mitigating a
lot of the searching that we would have
had to do so in that initial area
weren't finding tons and I don't know if
this is right or not but you know the
closer you get to a fob you have
security on the fob you have guys that
are looking out so it's hard for someone
to come in and dig out and put a knife
in the ground so you got some level of
security around the fobs most the time
yeah obviously there could be something
there pre-existing and day to day life
are you guys are you guys on MREs or you
guys getting chow or what's what's going
on day-to-day life oh man I wish we had
MRE so at some point during the
deployment we started on MREs mm-hmm you
know I like MREs I think they were good
you're sick I used to like em MREs when
I was like 22 and then I od'd on them I
didn't mind too much but then when we
started doing these pushes we got these
things called first strike rations like
the new MRE mmm but here's the problem
with these first right they're awesome
when we first got in the first week
they're awesome but the Marine Corps
only decided it would be good to buy
three different meals and kind of at the
same time we had outrun our water supply
so we were just stopping off at Wells
and guess what nobody he kind of
purifying stuff here so we were just
drinking well water and obviously what
you would expect to happen happened
everybody was getting sick just you know
diarrhea vomiting that's crazy no
purification tabs or I don't I guess
they didn't expect us to need to use
wells but the first day everybody ran
out of water by the by the time of the
we ended and we're like well we just got
to go get well water isn't that crazy a
purification pill is like I'm talking
about you echo like it's a little tiny
thing
you can carry him so easily and they
completely changed the game because you
can take that water out of a well or
stream that's got whatever bacteria on
it put that pill put that thing in there
shake it up you're good to go
does it taste different no not really
not really people use them camping this
iodine tablets yeah and you can also
bring a filter like when I hike I bring
a filter which is a little blank a Brita
pump no little pump little pump and how
long are you guys going out in the field
for let's see the first push to moose
claw was about two weeks and so we just
yeah walk for two weeks we walked to a
compound stop for the day set security
spend the night walk to the next one if
they shoot at us fight back
kill whatever do whatever we got to do
and then we just kept pushing out and
pushing out and then eventually we got
to a point in that first mousical ah
push where for whatever reason they just
they said alright now you're gonna walk
back I think I think maybe our I think
maybe our battalion commander had
actually he's been a little bit too
aggressive and had gone beyond his
limits that his boss wanted me to do
yeah so we ended up having to give up
territory we had just taken yeah and
yeah so that was two weeks but then once
we got to saying and it was pretty much
spend a day doing the push take the
compounds and then you kind of in the
compound you just go out of patrol then
you come back so we weren't really out
in the field field for all that long but
you know being in a compound still not
exactly luxury yeah you just don't have
showers and it's not the Kona Kai Resort
definitely alright man
I'm gonna talk about I'm gonna go to
your journal here cuz obviously on one
of these patrols you got hit and here's
what you wrote about it two things
happen simultaneously when whatever
explosive device that hit me exploded
first the shock wave cut through my toes
severing them it didn't slow as it cut
through my shins severing them next it
sent dirt grit and shrapnel upward into
my legs buttocks and any other part of
my body that was exposed next it
launched me a few feet into the air and
deposited me onto the ground unconscious
blood was pouring out of the newly
opened arteries and into the dirt muscle
and bone dangled from the remnants of my
legs vicious bacteria latched on and
invaded through the no new openings the
dust rose and settled and I woke up the
first ten seconds after waking up all I
could hear were my own screams all I
could see was a blurry tunnel looking up
to the sky the weird thing about the
screams was that my brain wasn't telling
my body to produce them it was almost as
if my mind was no longer present and my
body was just reacting or more like
panicking they were the kind of screams
that are emitted from a person
regardless of the consideration of the
personal pride that the person has no
matter how much their pride makes them
resist crying out they don't have a
choice in the matter they inhale to
lungfuls of air open their mouth as wide
as it will go and expel that air with
full force producing a scream that
pierces the air and changes pitch with
no control
as seconds clicked away my mind started
to come back online and my body calm
down
I stopped screaming and my other senses
returned I smelled dust and the unique
chemical smell of a recent explosion I
tasted it on my tongue and in my throat
after that my feeling came back it
wasn't so much pain as one would imagine
it but more like my lower legs had
fallen asleep for so long than it hurt
except magnified by fifty times I knew
that they were gone but how much I had
decided before I left on this deployment
that I could live with below the knee
amputations
but anything higher than that no thanks
I'd rather bleed out
I could hear Keith Johnson telling me
that they were coming for me and soon he
and Shane ought well were over me
applying tourniquets to the bleeding
stumps that used to be legs I mustered
up the courage to look at my hands
intact I moved them downward to check on
something vastly more important the
numbness I felt down there left me
unsure of its status just kill me
I croaked out they ignored me of course
and kept telling me how everything was
going to be okay they were holding my
hands as the corpsman knelt over me and
delivered the sweet sweet morphine that
made it all better
kill me man I said again I don't want to
live like this I think my dick is gone
your dick is still there man
do you want me to touch it Johnson asked
I chuckled with relief as I replied no
I asked whether the lug legs were gone
above or below the knee I was reassured
to hear that both were a few inches
below by this time I was high from the
morphine and was saying everything that
crossed my mind as the corpsman
continued to work and we waited for the
10 line Casa vac to be called in I
thought about all the things I wouldn't
be doing anymore
I thought about playing racquetball I
thought about working out in the gym I
thought about being in a wheelchair for
the next 50 years I never thought about
how I was breeding bleeding profusely
from two major arteries and could die I
never once thought I would die which may
seem unusual for a person in my position
naturally optimistic
I suppose although it is hard to claim
that I was being optimistic considering
I wanted to cash out permanently
in my defense I had no idea what life
was like as an amputee and if I had back
then I wouldn't have made that request
either way I'm glad I stuck around
around this time I decided to sit up and
take a look at the damage I took a deep
breath and gulped I slowly started
sitting up but when I got to the point
where going further a would reveal my
shredded legs I had a change of heart I
didn't see the blood-soaked dirt I
didn't see the disjointed lower parts of
my calf's and shins along with my feet
or the jagged edge of my remaining limbs
the skin roughly burned and shorn the
bone sticking out than the ripped muscle
dangling along the ground I didn't want
that image to be inside of my head
because I knew it would be one that I
would never be able to forget I deeply
regret the fact that there are those
that I consider friends that were forced
to have that image in their mind and
will have to live with with it for their
entire lives
secondly I was afraid of seeing the
wound would make it hurt even more much
like a scrape knee as a child I laid
back down and let the morphine keep
doing its job I started getting sleepy I
just wanted to close my eyes I thought
maybe if I closed my eyes I would pass
away easily
slap hot wells hand slapped my cheek as
he yelled at me to stay awake just let
me sleep just let me sleep I mumbled
closing my eyes again another slap that
was the last time I did that finally the
stretcher that was going to carry me out
arrived for strongmen lifted me onto it
grabbed each one of the handles and
started carrying me to an assault
breacher vehicle they were carrying me
away from the war I volunteered to
participate in and the Marines that I
was supposed to be leading and
protecting they would have to go on
without me all because I had failed in
my job failed to find the IE D that I
knew was somewhere around us that
failure was a hard pill to swallow then
and it remained so to this day I didn't
feel good about leaving them behind but
I knew they would understand I knew they
would be ok without me we got to the
assault breacher vehicle and I asked
Jimmy Goodwin one last time to put me
out of my misery
after his refusal that was the last time
I ever contemplated accepting that
Avenue they slid me into the back of the
vehicle and with some Marines I had
never met whose faces I can remember
seeing but don't remember any of their
features the corpsman said he was gonna
give me something to put me to sleep and
I finally got to close my eyes as
everything went black
you're pretty clear about what happened
I remember pretty lucidly
surprisingly yeah I don't know yeah I
was I think was unconscious for maybe 20
seconds I would estimate because they
hadn't even they hadn't gotten to me by
the time I woke up and I don't think
they would have spent a whole lot of
time yeah I think one of my guys might
have cleared over to me but I I don't
know I kind of wish I had thought of
something better to say like it got me
boys
free lesson learned reload a really cool
cinematic moment yeah and script yeah to
go with just in case a critical point oh
no I wish I would have thought of
something better than Dukes do there
make sense oh yeah that's something
vastly more important but the
interesting thing about they said I was
below the knee mm-hmm and so a lot of
the times what happens you might be
below the knee and site of injury but
like I said infection that dirt over
there is nasty we're not used to their
bacteria it'll get in there it'll infect
and they have to end up chopping you off
higher to save your life because the
infection is just uncontrollable and
also if they don't have viable tissue
bones and muscles that they can sculpt
in such a way that you can put a
prosthetic on there they'll just cut you
off we're at the next you know viable
spot really right and there's got to be
like you you know you had to have known
or you yeah you know this is a
possibility right in her over there how
much did you think about that
possibility it's probably the same thing
as when you were going through her body
I mean you know everybody knows you
could you could die you could get killed
yeah but it's not gonna be me
yeah it's probably gonna happen yeah but
you kind of have to do that don't you I
mean if you if you if I'm sitting there
sweeping and I'm thinking okay here we
go this could be it every step I'm not
gonna be effective yeah there's got to
be weather people refer to it the way I
refer to of like the idea of detachment
and you're just like not gonna think
about that everybody must be doing that
because otherwise you'd go freaking
crazy
like if you were just thinking this next
step could be the one I don't you do
you'd never be able to take a step then
you go out there I'm patrolling you see
Marines and soldiers and seals they
better know everyone's doing their job
just completely setting that fear aside
and saying okay that's a possibility
cool I don't have time to worry about
that right now I'm going to get it done
but I have I made a dark joke before I
went to Afghanistan I did this 5k with a
buddy he said oh we're gonna do it again
when when we get back from Afghan you
get back from Afghanistan I was like
yeah except you're gonna be pulling me
in a rickshaw cuz I'm gonna have both my
legs blown off he has yet to pull me in
the rickshaw not funny I talked about
you know fate or whatever I don't know
what what you know I don't know that's
Reiter that's just bad humor yeah that's
what we call that but you know what that
is that is a way you deal with these
things right oh you mean like hey we
were kind of talking about in the car
over here just like sick humor that you
end up with in the military because you
have to take that thought which is in
your head like it's got to be in your
head so what are you gonna do with it
are you gonna let it like burden you
down and make you inoperable and make
you not be able to do your job or you
know you know what we're gonna make a
joke about it yeah and that's how we're
gonna get through this so more than
anything else it's actually great I
should have said bad humor I should have
said great humor because that's the kind
of humor that I'm we'd hear that all the
time yeah you know all the time from
guys from my seals were ridiculous my
guys are just I mean the sickest sense
of humor you could imagine and but yeah
the same thing with the soldiers and
there wasn't even there's no barrier
like there's no barrier for that six
to humor when you're in the military
it's just like there and you're allowed
pretty much to say it across services
you know you can make a joke to a marine
or an army soldier about something and
they're not gonna beat they're not gonna
be offended by it it's gonna everyone's
got that same twisted sense of humor
that really if you think about it we're
all probably using to cope with you know
the fact that these bad things might
happen yeah I think I've often I try and
wonder why they say you know laughter is
the best medicine and and why it's so
true and it's I think it it acts to
normalize your situation so you know how
if you're about to try and deadlift like
a thousand pounds mine for you something
like that eight thousand if you're
trying to deadlift eight thousand pounds
and you're sitting there going there's
no way I'm going to deadlift this 8,000
pounds you're gonna go up to it and it's
gonna stick to the ground and that
predetermine a self predetermination
right and so if you're sitting there
let's say after I got hurt and I'm
sitting there going this is the worst
thing to ever happen this sucks
I hate this it's so serious it's such a
big deal then yeah it becomes the worst
thing that ever happened and I just kind
of get into that groove but if you can
make a joke about it it kind of makes
fun of it so it's not as serious mm-hm
and so when something's not as serious
or not as big a deal you make fun of
something it kind of becomes normal to
you and a little bit easier to to accept
like if you saw if I saw my drill
instructor crack a smile at any point if
you even like this is anything like that
then they automatically lose their their
persona yeah so if and you can tell
sometimes they were getting ready to
crack a smile and they'd be like yeah
they just walk it off they'd have to
just walk away so I think I think that
that's probably why you have to maintain
your humor in order to survive
you really do yeah no doubt about that
that's awesome
going back to your journal here it took
me 5 days to make it from the dusty
uncomfortable blast crater in
Afghanistan to a sterile uncomfortable
hospital bed in the ICU at the National
Naval Medical Center in Bethesda
Maryland luckily for me I was much too
high on what's that dil adored Dillard
allowed it dilaudid dilaudid yeah to
notice the bed or the trip my
amputations had started out below the
knee but somewhere during the three
hospital stops along the way the need
rose for the remaining portions below my
knees to be taken off a lot of the time
this is due to infections that are
picked up from the dirt in Afghanistan
or maybe there wasn't much that existed
below the knees to keep to make keeping
them viable on the bright side however
the stumps that were remaining were of a
significant length for an above knee
amputation I was left with the entire
femur on my left leg and only a few
inches shy on my right leg I found it
funny that throughout my entire hospital
stay the remainder of my legs were
always referred to as stumps by the
medical staff I had expected a more
elegant turn considering the fact that
this was a hospital at the same time
however I enjoyed the casual nature of
the word stump and even considered
naming them at one point later when
perusing my medical records I found the
elegant term I had been looking for
residual limb along with the major
injuries I sustained I also had a few
minor injuries I used the term minor
loosely here seeing as how these minor
injuries would be considered major if
they weren't sustained in tandem with
the severing of one's lower legs
starting from the lower person portions
first I lost a portion of the muscles
making up the inner part of my right
thigh in order to close that wound I
would require a skin graft taken from
the skin of my left thigh my buttocks
contain or sustain several large
from shrapnel some close to the
sphincter but mostly in the more meaty
parts that was okay though I have always
had an extra but muscle to go around the
close proximity of these wounds to the
working parts of the digestive digestive
system resulted in doctors diverting my
intestines to a colostomy bag that came
through my abdominal area the reason for
doing this wasn't because of any damage
to the intestines but because the
doctors wanted to make sure that the
large wounds on my butt didn't get
infected as for upper body injuries I
had some minor burns to my hands and two
totally perforated eardrums the hands
would heal and my eardrums would be
replaced with cartilage I consider
myself extremely lucky that I still have
all 10 fingers in perfect working
condition my eyes and most significantly
a brain that made it through the blast
with only a grade 3 concussion and no
residual traumatic brain injuries while
I may face hardships and have some sort
of discomfort constantly throughout the
day as a result of wearing prosthetics
at least it doesn't hurt I don't have
constant pain constant pain is much more
harrowing is a much more harrowing
plight than mine and I can't imagine how
hard it is to withstand I spent my first
week at Bethesda in the intensive care
unit I had a tube down my throat one
tube going into my arm a breathing tube
in my nose a catheter pads monitoring my
heart rate an epidural in my lower spine
and a wire from my pain button both my
hands were wrapped in gauze for my burns
my legs were also wrapped in gauze along
with having wound vac machines attached
them to suck out excess fluids leaking
from my wounds my rear end had a pad of
gauze for the wounds there the incision
down the center of my ABS used for my
colostomy had been stapled back together
and the bottom part parts of my stumps
were where the skin was reconnected were
stitched together
man like you know you just you it's just
piling all that other stuff onto and
just like you said you you lost your
legs and you're like oh you know that's
pretty much what a guy like me yeah I
focus oh he lost his legs you know
obviously freaking horrible and then you
don't a guy like me I'm not thinking
about all these other injuries that
you're sustaining and all the medical
things that have to happen to get that
stuff straightened out yeah
I mean any one of those just like if it
happen to one of us right now any one of
those would be major but they're just
pretty much nothing compared to the
actual major thing that happened and and
you're just so are you just drugged up
at this point yeah that first week I
mean yeah just dilaudid haze
hallucinations and that kind of thing
and surgeries I would hallucinate nasty
things like being hit by a mortar and
seeing my legs splattered for whatever
reason my mom was there and then I I
recall for the first couple weeks every
now and then I don't know how to
describe with something what happened
you felt the explosions before and
there's kind of that when the shock wave
goes through you and you kind of feel
your brain kind of jar a little bit and
I would kind of feel that and then for a
split second I would kind of it would be
like I was getting hit by an explosion
for a split second on it like that and
I'd be like then I just did I just pass
out or something good know what is that
so but that you know that kind of like
mental aftershock so yeah uh yeah I
don't know what it was it's I asked the
doctors about her they said I'm never I
don't know what that is but luckily it
went away and after maybe we had
something to do with the the drugs I
don't know but yeah but you know
eventually you get used to that body
kind of get sad
to it and you get your senses back and
it's hard to look at a computer screen
for the first couple weeks still but
eventually I would see ants crawling on
me but yes you know so eventually all
that kind of goes away and you just
stuck with your little button for pain
I remember they you can only hit the
that all unless you hit it every three
four or five minutes or something like
that and they would come in during the
first little bit and they would say you
know you can only hit that thing like 12
times in a minute right so yeah and they
said well you hit it about a hundred and
ten times in the last hour
well IV I because I'd be kind of like
falling asleep and then I hit it and do
they know make sure I make sure I got
that hit so I just hit it again and so
yeah and then but eventually kind of get
used to it and pain starts to go away
I'm sitting here thinking about like
I've been hospitalized a couple times
for a couple different surgeries and
what a complete pussy I was you know in
there like this urge you know and I had
you know this is this is through you
know repair something like I had a
hernia operation I had a neck surgery
like these are planned operations yeah
the openings in my body were made by a
highly skilled surgeon you know and
they're like oh this sucks I mean I
can't I think what you have is like a
thousand times
a thousand times worse and it's it's
hard to even imagine and then on top of
this I'm going back to the journal here
to top it all off I had my pirate hat on
my head
I was practically being held together by
duct tape like an old dilapidated chair
you're trying to get one or one more
good year out of what's up with a pirate
hat well so you're not supposed to wake
up when you go through Germany so
basically you go from site of injury to
Camp Leatherneck to Bagram Air Force
Base to launch tool Germany to Bethesda
Maryland for Marines and then just go
straight to Walter Reed for anybody else
Marines and sailors
Desna and so for whatever reason I wake
up in Germany for mono 15-20 minutes and
my squad leader was there he was there
for something else I don't remember what
he wasn't here for but so he was there
I know and you kind of told me what
happened and that kind of thing and I
just I couldn't help but think even
though the super drugged up was like my
mom is gonna not she's gonna be sad and
so all I could think of I'm always
trying to crack a joke or whatever so I
was like see if you can see if you can
find a funny hat everyone and he gonna
find one right they're not gonna have
funny hats in the hospital it's a
serious place he went looked I guess
maybe he just went outside the room I
couldn't find one we didn't go to a
funny hat
Bagram has a lot of thing or Germany has
a lot of things but maybe not a funny
hat store so couldn't find one I get to
Bethesda and when you get to the
hospital they pick you up from wherever
they fly you into in these big basically
semi tractor-trailer hasa
ambulances and they they have they alert
the hospital or we're coming we're gonna
be there 2 p.m. and all the doctors come
down and they rush you in and do what
you need to do and so a lot of the times
that's where families will see their
their servicemen when they first get
back when they're unloading them and
they give them kind of you know 15-20
seconds - oh good - Zia and then they
take you off and I don't know how it
happened but I'm rolling down the thing
and there's my mom she has this pirate
hat in her hand
I don't know if somehow they got board
back to her still don't know then oh uh
no I haven't I think I think somebody
else brought it uh-huh
I don't think she brought about I don't
know why they would have brought me a
my red hat unless somebody had found out
that I had asked for a stupid hat or
something I've never been known to wear
you know pirate hats or stupid hats
before so there's my mom with a stupid
hat and then so it kind of became a
theme or people would bring me a stupid
hat wouldn't they came and visited me so
I had a big bag but so I guess what
happened you know I hope it kind of
helped my ease the pain a little bit for
my mom in that initial that initial
meeting maybe a little bit but I don't
know so then you spend how long you and
are you in like ICU for where they're
trying to get you more stabilized I was
probably there for about a week and then
you move up to the the fifth floor of
the hospital which is kind of where they
put all the amputees and there are
actually three Joneses there at the time
so the nurses had to be very careful and
on top of that my I'm Jones are our
first two initials my buddies who got
hit maybe an hour before me his name is
Jones Dee Dee and then the third Jones
was Jones JJ Bing so they had to be on
it with you know with checking what
medications are going to you Shh but
yeah so that's then you go up to the
fifth floor and that's kind of where you
start to become lucid and that's where
the physical therapists start to come in
and that's where once you're kind of
ready like you start just lifting a leg
110 times just lift your stomach and you
describe that in your journal it was
like exhausting for you yeah and it hurt
and what's making it is it because
you've been laying there for so long is
because it's a movement that you haven't
been able to do in a while I know just
all the above I would imagine a lot of
that stuff down there is just swollen
and painful you know that's I think
that's probably what it would be and so
yeah it hurts so bad just even move it
at all and so they start with that and
then eventually you get in your
wheelchair and it takes about ten
minutes for you to get into your
wheelchair and take
for people to get you into your
wheelchair you're just like sliding off
and you just so sore but you know
eventually you get better and I could
you know I made a big deal about the
first day that I got my wheelchair by
myself and then I would go for little
rolls around the floor and somebody
would have to like wheel my my little IV
pole and I have to hang my catheter bag
on the I was so scared I was so like
watch that tube do not let that tube get
caught into anything and so yeah I would
I would just do a few laps around the
ward get out and then when I was done I
could visit my buddy Daniel cuz he
couldn't get out of bed yet cuz he had a
I don't I don't know why he can get out
of bed but he couldn't get out of bed so
I'd go in his room and hang out for a
little while so then and and then how
long is it before you're thinking to
yourself okay or what makes you start
thinking well this is my game plan this
is where I'm going like you see guys
that are further along the process and
you say okay I see what that guy's doing
you know yeah III I'm gonna do that too
well I sent a little I phone message to
Daniel who is due down and still down on
the fifth floor my buddy took a little
they want you to see something Daniel
and so I said listen first step make a
workout program to get back to where we
were before to get on our feet again so
it was a media I was like we are going
to just work out and we're gonna get
better and you know so they don't do a
whole lot of prosthetics at Bethesda
well they do now but they didn't back
then and so the nurses would kind of
have a general idea of how the
prosthetic stuff went and the physical
therapists would know but the major
thing was the visits from Walter Reed so
the Wounded Warrior battalion people
would bring people that were further
along in their recovery over to visit
the guys that just been freshly wounded
and so I got one of those visits I don't
remember there being a double above the
knee amputee that came to see me that
was in legs yet but they had a better
idea and they would say look you know
you're gonna get over there and you're
gonna get your prosthetics and you're
gonna be able to walk again you're gonna
be able to run you're gonna be able to
do this and that and so at that point
like oh so I'm not gonna know I don't
have to be in a wheelchair forever oh
okay you know so it was about at that
point
and then what do how did you develop
your workout program well uh once I
became lucid I was doing pull-ups on my
little triangle
you know how they had the little
triangle thing dangling down started
getting after I wasn't doing well I was
doing pull-ups I was probably doing like
horizontal rows or something no it's
just like lifting myself up whenever the
physical therapist couldn't come in and
do her stuff with me I was there I was
gonna do it pull myself up on this thing
and so that was I and I kind of I went
off the therapists experience for the
foremost of it in the in the beginning
until I kind of got on my own because I
don't you know they're they've been
doing this for nine years at that point
so they had a lot of drills and
strengthening exercises that I can do
and and that kind of thing so I just
kind of let them take the reins and just
did whatever they said and then did it
again
but then once I got to a point where I
was we're kind of Larry where you see me
now I'm walking around no problem that's
when I started venturing into trying to
do regular gym stuff mm-hmm and I
invented my own way of doing straight
leg deadlift so it's I strapped myself
to a pole and I cinch it down she leaned
down and I do a straight leg deadlift
doesn't put because I can't squat right
right
I thought this was a really cool party
or Journal that you wrote and you're
talking about getting through that kind
of stuff so here we go back to the
journal it is easy to be motivated to
succeed in the beginning of an endeavor
and when you are close to the end the
most difficult part and the part where
people quit is when they are in the
thick of it and it is unclear whether
they have the strength and stamina to
make it the rest of the way while I
never actually doubted my ability to
walk again during my recovery I am
certainly subject to the inner monologue
rationalizing why it is okay to quit or
to not push myself to the goal that I
have written down on paper one way I
have recognized to aid in shutting that
monologue the fuck up is celebrating
milestones the hardest part of working
toward a goal is when we are either
making slow progress or negative
progress and having the patience and
confidence to know that the improvements
we make over the long periods as opposed
to the short periods are what matter
milestones are what remind us that we
are making progress even if it isn't
apparent every day in rowing I've heard
of people that count strokes until the
finish line using sets of 10 personally
I like to count to 50s for making up a
race when I ran the nation's triathlon I
picked points ahead of me to make it to
and when I got there I'd pick a new
point anything we can use to keep our
minds from succumbing to the monologue
will work not only ensure short-term
goals but also in long-term goals like
graduating from college or learning to
use prosthetics great advice for anybody
to pay attention to
now you mentioned rowing there mm-hmm so
this was no like weekend row that you
decided to do this so you got after it
yeah
so how'd that come about so I was I was
looking for that workout program I knew
at this point hey I'm alive I'm gonna
still try and have the best life
possible and so I'm trying to get back
what I what I lost so to speak and I
used to like working out and going to
the gym getting after it
and so I'm sitting there going well
what's the new what's another way that I
can work out now and so I started
looking up I forget what I looked up and
disabled sports or disabled work it like
Google something and Google getting
after you at Google
and so the Paralympics comes up is
apparently no the Olympics I don't know
what the Paralympics is is that like the
Special Olympics and the answer that
question is no and so the Paralympics is
the Olympics for disabled people for
people with disabilities
it's like all right well I fit into that
category let's see what sports they got
and I saw they had rowing so well you
know what I used to I used to hit the
rowing machine when I was working out
and getting on the concept - yeah the
concept - doing some sprints on that
thing that was pretty tough and I want
something that's tough
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
see I'm gonna look into this rowing
thing and maybe oh maybe I'll make the
Paralympics one day and this is when I
was just got to the hospital a second
week in the hospital not not real strong
point in the picture hey you gotta save
yourself a goal right away yeah you
don't have but something you're working
towards then you just you know treading
water and so yeah and hey a lot of
things fell into place
there was a I probably didn't go out and
try and learn to row on the water until
the next year so I was my main focus at
that
I was still learning the prosthetics
getting my strength back but once I kind
of got my strength back and I was right
I felt like I was ready to move on kind
of outside of the therapy angle on it
I looked up places where I could learn
to row and I mean just so happened there
was one in DC and so I went down there
and I learned and I mean I don't want to
brag but the guy said I wasn't natural
so so they won't maybe I can do this and
so I convinced the they didn't have raw
machine in the physical therapy clinic
at the time they had an elliptical mmm
they had all sorts of quiver they didn't
have a raw machine so I convinced the
clinic whoever was running the clinic to
get a rowing machine for me so I could
row and then when I was training for the
nation's Rathlin I convinced them to let
me bring my bike in and and ride my bike
in the clinic so I had my own starting
to build my own gym inside the gym and I
convinced them to get a kettlebell for
me and stuff and so I convinced them to
let me let me have that raw machine and
so a couple times a week I would go down
to the water and train on the water the
other times I would just do some sprints
on the on the rowing machine and then it
just kind of kept I kept getting better
and better and this is 20011
so then the Paralympics for 2012 and now
is there is there like a specific coach
that that runs the the rowing team there
isn't in some sports there are there's
like there's a head coach is in charge
of everybody and he'll train everybody
but for my category and Paralympic
growing it's pretty much you find your
own coach and you show up at this race
and if you win that race then you
represent America and all the races for
that year dang how far is the row it's a
thousand meters so what is that like it
takes you a couple minutes three minutes
so we're only
shrunken arms only was my category so it
would take me my best ever time on the
ERG was product 338 I think and that's
like puke level puttin out yeah for me
yeah yeah
and then on the water the best in a
double so two people my category you
have to have two people in the boat was
just right around four minutes if you
could do four minutes then you had a
shot at winning and that's a thousand
meters to it's a thousand meters so
you're always gonna be a little bit
slower on the water and you say it's
four minutes you said yeah about four
minutes so it's like a gut complete gut
check it's it's the equivalent of
sprinting like oh the mile yeah cuz
you're going four minutes right oh man a
mile I mean it's it's no joke it's a
it's a tough it's a tough tough race and
where was the Paralympics that year the
Paralympics were in London in 2012 and
so I was just getting ready for that I
was getting ready to retire I need
something to do too and just so happened
that my coach that at the time knew
somebody else do this this other coach
that had a female that was looking for a
partner also a double above the knee
amputee and so my boat class is one guy
one girl and so we met up rode together
looked like we were pretty good pair and
once I retired moved down to Florida
start training for the Paralympics how
long did you have to train so I got out
in late December let's they call it
January first and I we had the the
Paralympic finals September 2nd or
September 3rd ok so you had a decent
chunk of time but yeah good nine months
of crushing yourself of yeah training
twice a day every day or twice a day 6
days a week
take off Sunday and just
Sprint's you know technique a lot
technique
yeah do you have to do the technique in
the water yeah I mean you can do it
outside of the water a little bit but
it's really you got to practice your
technique in in the water a service like
jiu-jitsu you've got a it doesn't matter
if you if you're doing like a in a fake
fake scenario yet it doesn't really have
the same effect unless you're doing it
in the real thing
yeah so you get to England and boom yeah
how many races is there in England is it
just one race no luckily there's a
couple races so we had to do win the
trials race okay which was to find out
who represented America we won that and
then we had to go qualify our boat for
the Paralympics and so we had to go to
Serbia about a maybe a month after when
in the trials to qualify the boat so we
won that race qualified our boat and
then Paralympics you show up and you do
your heat and then if you win that he is
how many boats turn heat six bang so
there were 12 boats stole six in each
heat two dots so if you win that heat
you automatically go to the final if you
don't win that heat you got to go what's
called the repechage mm-hmm
stands for second chance in French and
you have to come first or second in that
so we won our repechage we lost our heat
to the Chinese which still makes me so
mad and we won our repechage so we were
in the final and we started the final
and dead last and just slowly over the
course of the race this was our race
plan we kind of wanted to start slow and
build slowly we just rode in one boat
and the next boat and the next boat
until we got to the end and we're about
six inches between us and the great
british mode the home team everybody's
cheering for the home team and so third
place gets a medal fourth place you
don't get anything you get nothing
yeah so and we're doing our final sprint
and then we crossed the line
and I don't know I I wasn't looking over
there my forearms were numb I was just
trying to hold onto the oars and then it
comes up on this little board you know
first place China second place France
and then this is this long it goes third
place USA and you look at the video
it's literally like the length of one of
these knives no cooter yeah that close
Oh point two point two seconds between
them and us that's crazy so close so did
you meet anyone while you're on that
event you tell me you met someone over I
gotta back oh well so I'll tell you when
we were first got there and we were
training we were doing we would go out
we probably there a good week beforehand
so we'd go out and train on the lake and
continue our training get used to the
area My partner my my rowing partner and
I were watching the other teams and then
there's another boat class called the
four so it's four people and I saw this
great British for robaix and there was
this gorgeous blonde in the bow of the
four and I said I just bit my lip that's
a good-looking chick and you know I
didn't I never expected to meet her or
anything cuz you know we're not racing
against each other and she's from
another team and you kind of you know
until the race is over they're gonna be
keeping a professional sure she even
though she was super hot but you know
and she she
she'll tell me back when she told me
what she saw me around I was like
because I was a now assistant serious
Marine Corps mode yeah don't talk to
anybody
yeah
and so uh Racing's over we're back in
the athletes village it's time to get
after it the other kind of getting after
it there's a casino outside the athletes
village so the American contingent goes
out to this casino starts we're part I'm
still at this point I'm still kind of in
like serious mode takes a couple days to
get out of it you know serious serious
mode still a little bit pissed that we
lost and you know to China and France
it's like the two people the two
countries that my buddies like don't
lose the China or France they were
taking shots like every to fit they were
following on at home and they they woke
up like so early in the morning so we're
out there then the the British team
comes in for their just won gold right
and they're all they're all happy so
we're the only two groups that speak
English right so yeah so our two groups
you know kind of end up together and it
took it took him a while to get me two
out of my shell because I was like you
know still kind of on my guard
I yeah this is the first then maybe the
second time I'd ever traveled outside of
America for anything besides deployments
yeah I'd never traveled outside of
America but Serbia was the first time
England was the second time so it's kind
of still on my guard a little bit but
they started feeding me Fosters mm-hmm
lightened up and then just so happened
the the gorgeous blonde I saw was there
so hey you guys know how charming I am
Charmander well you at least fooled her
I'm sure the alcohol helped you know but
charmed her and now we're married so
that's all
after four years of long-distance
relationship because he kept Rowan she
she actually defended her gold medal and
Rio and did it again yeah got gold again
so we did about we didn't get together
right away we we did a long-distance for
about three years she living in England
and I was living in America but finally
got her over here married her name's Pam
nice well obviously I have a certain
affinity for British ladies this way
that's pretty well known
now you mentioned real quickly you were
training for a triathlon in there
somewhere too yeah so the people at the
clinic it was uh I mean it was a team
effort everybody so there were other
other amputees than there and I mean we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
Dan Connaughton Navy SEAL yeah that was
there for a year awesome guy before and
and Paralympian as well yeah oh yeah
Paralympian of the biathlon he was my my
idol I guess for when I first got there
cuz he was pretty much done with therapy
he was about to get out he was walking
everywhere on his legs carrying backpack
around and he was almost I mean the
exact same injuries you I mean just
above the knee yeah yeah and so I could
see him from when I was just sitting in
a wheelchair right all right that it's
possible you know because I'm seeing it
with my own eyes it is possible and so
and he's a stud and yeah if you want to
if you want to try and be like anybody
it's be like yeah because and so that's
kind of the the environment that they
had there at Walter Reed was you could
ask somebody that had been there before
tips tricks anything like that and so I
saw Dan and I was asking him stuff and
watching how he did stuff and then
eventually he left and I kind of noticed
you know I am now there's new guys
coming in I'm now that person that has
been there and so I need to step into
that role and offer advice and
work harder than anybody else in the
clinic and show people what's going on
and show people what's possible and so
the therapist would always be hey you
want who wants to run the army 10-miler
who wants to do this triathlon they'd
always be getting offers they'd all be
getting slots and races because people
love having wounded warriors out there
it's a they make a big deal when they
get let them go off first and everything
so yet so and every time they ask me if
I could if I wasn't doing anything else
that day be like yeah yeah I'll do it
and so they're like you want to do the
nation's triathlon it's Olympic distance
triathlon and there's like two people
doing it and no other it's like it's
single below the knee amputee doing it
and that's it and you're a double above
in the empty you want to do it yeah I do
and sure it's so because it just so
happened at the time I was learning how
to ride a bicycle again normal bicycle
so you're learning how to ride a bike
might as well do a triathlon exactly hey
one of the things that's gonna drive you
to push yourself is having skin in the
game having something to lose having
something to risk so if you say to
everybody in the clinic I'm going to do
the nation's triathlon and you don't do
it you're an idiot
yeah you're a loser yeah what do you how
is a Olympic triathlon distance the swim
is 1,500 meters the bike is 40
kilometers and the run is 10 kilometers
jack
luckily for me because I was not that
good at swimming luckily for me the swim
got canceled that year because there was
a huge storm as a ton of debris in the
Potomac uh-huh so we didn't do the swim
but we did the bike and the run and yeah
so what I was relearning how to ride a
bicycle nobody had ever done that before
and the history of Walter Reed doubled
above the knee amputee trying to ride a
bicycle and I had figured it out and I
kind of wanted to put it to use you know
like I finally figured this thing out
and so oh what better way to do it then
do the nation's triathlon
and so it was like you know baptism by
fire in a way and so it took me like
four hours to do the whole thing did you
enjoy it I enjoyed having done it okay
because I'm just wondering at what point
you made the brilliant decision that you
were gonna ride a freaking bicycle
across the United States of America well
which was your next whatever freaking
psychotic idea you got again would that
come from I had just learned how to ride
the bike I'm going I got do something
with it I can't make it just this point
listen I learned okay I did it and now
never gonna do it again like you know
what might be fun is this like riding my
bike across the country at some point in
my life and this is what I have I'm not
even I'm still in the hospital I just
learned how to ride the bike I should do
something like ride my bike across
countries you know some some cool like
that and I was wrong I didn't do it
right oh because I had made the
commitment to do the rowing rows I'm
gonna do rowing but eventually I will do
this cross-country bike ride and so I
did another year of rowing after that I
I took the time to kind of plan it out
how I wanted to do it and so it took
another year rowing and then finished
World Championships that year and forth
and about a month later drove up to
Maine started riding this is in October
and so what was the what was at all what
was the what did that day-to-day look
like uh so I had a box truck a u-haul
box truck I bought like I used two
hundred thousand miles u-haul box truck
check my back I laid down some carpets
in the back check had a couple cots a
couple sleeping bags surprise and my
little brother who was about to turn 18
check
Roger DUP to drive good to go that's all
you need right there box truck water to
cots carpet and a little brother
and so you know I didn't really train
much what I did was I made sure that my
prosthetics fit correctly and I was able
to ride the bike that's all I really did
I didn't you know go out and ride 100
miles or anything any kind of formal
training for it yeah because I figured
what is the point yeah yeah exactly this
start and the beginning is the training
for the finish yeah so the day-to-day
would be wake up probably six seven
o'clock you know drive out to wherever I
was starting for the day because you
couldn't you can't just like stop and
then pull over so we'd have to like
drive the truck somewhere park it in a
church parking lot or a fire department
parking lot and then yes we don't get
apprehended by the cops
so the first time so I had I was right
I'd be riding my bike and then my
brother would be kind of half on half
off the road and I picked a route that
we didn't have you know not super busy
roads so I wouldn't get in too many
people's way until I got the Pacific
Coast Highway and then people were super
pissed and at one point this cop the for
the first cop I encountered pulls over
in front of us am i all right here we go
he's gonna tell me to stop rides over
and then he gets out he's like I just
want to shake your hand man like whew
okay this is how it's gonna go this is
awesome so I'm gonna get the cops love
me and so I wake up start riding
probably around 7:30 8:00 I might eat
breakfast beforehand probably ride I
would do 30 miles a day so I just break
that up however I felt for the day take
breaks
hop in the back of the truck sit around
for a while and run I'd ride 30 miles
and then wherever I finished 30 miles I
might go a little bit further for a
better spooling off point stop get in
the truck drive off to wherever we might
be able to park the truck and then
to spend the night in the truck and then
drive back out to that spot the next day
do it again luckily for me a lot of
hotels started to offer us nights sleep
so we really only sleep in the truck for
the first month then after that we were
mostly in hotels and this was like a six
month journey six months October to Rock
Tober - April OC dude through the winter
tanya you ever heard of the polar vortex
is like this freezing temperatures that
came down and and like attacked the
nation with cold they called the polar
vortex it sounded very it's one step
higher than a sharknado 5000 180 miles
in the winter time every day for 180
days to talk about fortitude in your
journal and I'm gonna read it it was
through it was through the true purpose
of the Marine Corps that I became what I
am today and it is that it is that and
that is the act of fighting the battles
of the United States it is through the
preparation for and the fighting of
America's wars that Marines gain their
fine edge and an idea of the true
meaning of courage spirit tenacity
altruism and brotherhood after having
been imbued with the essential qualities
described to Marines in boot camp it is
up to the individual marine and his
leadership all the way from the fireteam
leader to the Commandant to make him the
ideal tool for the Corps and there's no
better place than a war to do this it
was during my two deployments that I
learned what it means to be courageous
almost on a daily basis my fellow
Marines and I would be subjected to
situations with high potential for
danger and situations with infinite
unknowable possible outcomes the
dangerous and unpredictable made
these conditions elicits fear
nervousness and uncertainty in all
people
however without fail when the time came
to strap on our gear and proceed forth
into these conditions we did it with no
hesitation because it was what we needed
to do to me that is courage I learned it
from the example set by my leaders and
my compatriots and when it was my turn I
endeavored to teach others by my own
example my favorite among the many
mantras of the Marine Corps is adapt and
overcome it is my favorite because it
embodies the spirit and tenacity that
Marines must possess in order to be the
world's greatest war fighting force to
Marines accomplishment of their mission
is of the utmost importance
above that of their own lives and the
ability to adapt and overcome is key
the idea is straightforward change
whatever you need to in order to become
what is required to transcend an
obstacle if there is no bridge over a
river a marine will swim if there is a
wall in front of us we will blow it
apart if there is an enemy on a hill
that we want we will remove him Marines
do not stop until they have accomplished
their mission regardless of any monkey
wrench that gets thrown into their plan
they will change their plane plan a
thousand times if it need be until what
needs to be done is done and then they
will move on to the next mission it was
these two qualities that kept me that
allowed me to keep fighting after I was
wounded my plan of accomplishing
something with my life and making my
life as good as possible was met with
obstacles and monkey wrenches but since
I had already learned these lessons by
passing these obstacles
and moving on was easy and natural the
Brotherhood that the Marines share is
the defining feature that initially
attracted me to the Marine Corps and
over the course of two deployments I
experienced it to its fullness the
reason that I was able to be courageous
and adapt and overcome was because the
men that stood beside me doing the same
thing and is because we were
experiencing war and hardship together
that we goö grew close enough that I
cared for them more than I cared for
myself and would sacrifice my safety for
their well-being even if it meant being
extinguished and although it never
needed to be said I knew this was
reciprocated
to me this is the definition of
brotherhood and selflessness and from my
having been part of such a relationship
is why I am loyal and put others before
myself as if it were a default setting
without the Marine Corps I have no idea
where I would be or what I would be like
all I can say for sure is that I am what
I am now due in large part to what I was
taught and what I experienced during my
five years in the Marine Corps
yeah awesome if there's anything that
the Marine Corps teaches you it is
Brotherhood it is endurance how to
endure situations you don't want to have
to be here
whether it's humping around with a pack
or fighting in Afghanistan Iraq or if
it's sitting in the back of a 7-ton
getting drenched in rain and then having
to set up a tent bla bla bla it teaches
you those things and so I already knew
all this stuff I was good at it
by the time I became an amputee and then
I got even better at it once I was an
amputee even more experience and then so
that led into being able to endure
whatever I had to for the bike ride and
I think the slogan slogan for the
Wounded Warrior Regiment and the Marine
Corps is I don't know if this is it's
Latin I don't know if it's I'm
pronouncing it right atiim in pugna
which is still in the fight and you know
I'm not still in the main fight that's
going on in Iraq or Afghanistan I've
been taken out of that fight but the
overall fight I'm still in that I'm
still a representative of America I'm
still a representative of Marines I'm
dedicating myself to help my brothers
that are struggling or come back wounded
I'm still in that portion of the fight
and I mean just remember you just have
to remember that that's Logan to stay
stay in the fight just keep fighting or
obviously you're staying in the fight
and I you know I you again reading
through your journal stuff
is awesome and there's a bunch of
different things that I wanted to pull
out and obviously I can't read the whole
damn thing right maybe I could but I'll
leave that for you but one of the things
you know I'm always thinking that what
you know what can I pull out that I
think will be really helpful to other
people and I thought that this thing
that you wrote right here was just
something that can be used by by anybody
especially people that are facing tough
situations which as you just mentioned
you are pretty dang good at tough
situations and I think this gives a
little insight into that so here we go
back to your journal
the kubler-ross model explains the
stages by which an individual grieves
for a lost intimate the five stages are
denial anger bargaining depression and
acceptance in this case it could be said
I was grieving for myself
the former me that had died in Sangin
since I had a natural understanding of
conservation of energy and an awareness
of the time required to reach my goal I
instinctively skipped the first four
steps and proceeded the acceptance
portion of the process I had decided
that to spend my limited energy
resources on denial anger bargaining and
depression would be a pointless waste
and would be better left off of my
itinerary I wanted to be able to expend
as much energy as I could toward my goal
which would not only allow me to reach
it faster but would improve the quality
of my success
the sooner I had accepted my situation
the sooner I could get to where I wanted
to be having one's legs amputated above
the knee is categorically a negative
experience if I hadn't had the right
mindset afterward the rest rest of my
life could have also become a negative
experience fortunately I was able to
react to the loss by accepting the
negative energy from that occur
and using it to open doors for myself in
order to be sure that my life would
remain a positive experience no matter
who you are whether you are healthy or
ill injured or able-bodied everyone's
main purpose in life is to make it as
good as possible this is an unchanging
objective for all people no matter what
happens
thus now that I was a double
above-the-knee amputee I needed to
figure out a way to keep my life
enjoyable with this in mind I researched
the Paralympics to see if I could
participate which led to a bronze medal
at the 2012 games not only that I
accepted people into my life who have
enriched it beyond what I could have
imagined from the experiences associated
with sports I have learned lessons that
have and will continue to make me a
better person
lessons that I can pass on to others in
the future it was in this way that I was
able to transform the negative
experience of having lost the lower part
of my legs into the positive experience
and energy of participating in a sport
and all that has accompanied it if you
are ill or injured use it as a way to
discover a new hobby or career if
someone is rude to you and makes you
angry use the anger to fuel a workout if
someone you know has a terminal illness
use it as an opportunity to make a
difference in their life and in the
world the most important part of
transforming energy from negative to
positive is being aware of opportunities
as they are presented and having the
courage to seize them energy is all
around us constantly fueling and
transforming it will affect us in a ways
we cannot be for we cannot predict be a
person that uses energy intelligently
instead of wasting it I like to say use
the weight and I kind of analogize it I
like to lift weights I'm sure you guys
can probably tell I like to analogize it
with maybe like a strict press so the
weight on the bar is whatever girlfriend
broke up with you whatever possible
issue you're having and you can hold
that bar on your shoulders and you can
just leave it there and eventually start
to hurt and then eventually if you leave
it there long enough you'll just be on
the ground with that weight on your
chest
you can't move anymore or when you have
that weight on the bar and it's on your
shoulders your shoulder press it and
they do it again and you do it again and
again and then you let your body adapt
and next time you try and lift that
weight it's nothing
you can do that weight easily I can
handle that no problem and then you can
handle even more weight and then when
you get good at that you seek out the
weight you purposefully try and make
things harder for yourself so that you
can just become even stronger and even
stronger and you embrace that and you
start to enjoy it a little bit and so I
mean that I think that's what I was
trying to say there I think you said it
not only that you say it but uh you
actually are living that currently at
this time seeking out more I guess maybe
I would even go so far as to say stupid
things to do
so the next challenge that you put in
front of yourself is the thing that
you're about to do right now and I've
never heard of a challenge like this
before but you're gonna do a month of
marathons yeah so these things are only
stupid or crazy if I fail bike rides not
crazy because I did
but if I had failed then people could
say it's crazy so I'm fail this one that
it's stupid now man I'll tell you what
you you going out there and making these
things happen you know it's awesome
whether you finished or not well no
matter what you do the fact that you're
putting these hardcore challenges in
front of yourself is it's it's
unbelievable yeah so yeah all this stuff
that I've written down and what we've
talked about all the wisdom I've been
able to to gain through my injury and
through being in the Marine Corps I
think this the month of marathons I'm
about to do this and everything else
that I that I try and do I'm trying to
be an example because there's so many
people out what but when I was trying to
learn the right how the bike again I
didn't know anybody that had ever done
it before until I saw somebody that had
done it and has made everything once you
realize it's possible it makes it so
much easier because you know it's it can
be done and so I want to be an example
for people to look at and they see me
and they say well they might not be
trying to run thirty-one marathons in 31
days in 31 different cities or ride
their bike across the country but they
can say there's a double above knee
amputee that ran 31 marathons in 31 days
I can probably go walk on the treadmill
so if I just want to be an example of
that and I want to be an example of all
of these lessons that I've learned a
person that uses the weight instead of
let's it destroy their life somebody
that stays in the fight keeps fighting
no matter what that's what I'm trying to
do I want to serve to show people what
they can do and especially you know
wounded veterans and people that might
be struggling with what they saw and you
know I'm lucky enough that my mind is
clear I had a grade three concussion
that's it no traumatic brain injury nope
traumatic stress nothing like that and
so I want to show civilians and veterans
alike that it is possible to have a
traumatic experience and come through
and be fine and not have not have to
suffer from post-traumatic stress that
just overwhelms you
because I think in society these days
it's almost becoming expected that
you're gonna go to war and you're gonna
come back and so a lot of people might
end up in a wall I'm supposed to have
post-traumatic stress so I'm going to
sort of manifest it in myself or they
let it get worse or they don't they
don't fight it they just let it happen
and so I want to be an example of
somebody that uses their experience and
it's just goes and has this terrible
experience and you know don't make a big
deal about it and part of you doing that
is running 31 freaking marathons in 31
days yeah so when do you start so I'm
gonna start in 31 different cities 31
different cities my first city London
London on October 12th and then I'm
going to fly to Philadelphia
so basically way it's gonna work I'll
run in a city probably take about the
whole thing I'll take breaks during the
during the run so I'll probably the
whole thing will probably take five and
a half six hours to do I'll do run on my
own just like in a park or on a trail
out in backs loops I'll do it on a 400
meter track if I have to do that get in
my RV drive to the next place spend the
night there we upgraded from a box truck
with the goths in the back well the
wife's gonna be coming along so
you know I'm gonna have a crew for this
one I got my wife Pam is gonna be my
team leader sees she's is doing so much
stuff she's a team leader and everything
every job that you could possibly think
of she's doing it and my mom is coming
cuz he's a massage therapist if she's
gonna nice get a massage and I'm gonna
have a driver not my brother this time I
think I blew him out I'm gonna have a
driver and so we're gonna all hop in the
RV drive to so from Philadelphia to New
York run in New York repeat until I go
all the way around I'm gonna end
November 11th Veterans Day DC on the
National Mall and and your goal
obviously is to show people and lead
people and set an amazing example and on
top of that you're gonna earn you're
gonna you're gonna earn money for some
real specific charities that that you
believe in and stand behind and one of
those charities yeah so my goal my main
goal is obviously the to be the example
all these kind of grand objectives but
you know how do you really you can't
quantify that really so the way that I'm
quantifying it is I'm going to be
raising money for three veterans
charities that I've had personal contact
with that have helped me during my
recovery and they are the Semper Fi fund
the tunnel to towers foundation and the
coalition to salute America's Heroes and
so that's how I'm going to be that's
also I'm going to be showing veterans
that America loves them because that is
something that's been made abundantly
clear to me everywhere I go all the time
I think I did three breakfasts in a row
where somebody paid for it anonymously
I get thanked all the time and so if
they're saying that stuff to me it's
obvious that they love all veterans and
I'm trying to help connect that just
reduce that gap between the military and
the civilian worlds and get them to talk
and
and show that show veterans that they're
coming back to a country that
appreciates them and loves them more
than pretty much any other thing and so
I think by the donations and by having
people come out and run with me and show
me support then that kind of helps us to
prove that to people so where can we go
donate what's the what's the link Rob
Jones journey.com
Rob Jones journey.com there's a there's
a donate link there and you can also see
my schedule there and I'll have details
of where I'm gonna be and it's the whole
country it's East Coast West Coast yeah
middle country all the way around far so
you can drive in a day to get to a next
spot to run 26.2 yeah my longest drive
is 1214 hours and that happens maybe
once or twice so it's they're all pretty
close to each other in major cities and
yeah you can go to my website Rob Jones
journey.com donate there see my schedule
RSVP that you're gonna show up you don't
have to if you but if you want to that's
cool I'll have all the details there and
then social medias all at Rob Jones
journey awesome I it's awesome man it's
just awesome and you're freaking awesome
and I grabbed a couple this a little
short piece from your journal again this
is something that I just thought is is
just gonna be helpful to me when I read
it and will be helpful to anybody that
that listens hears or reads this and
here we go back to your journal the
conscious is in control of forming
habits every time we are faced with a
decision of whether to quit slow down
and rationalize a reason why that's okay
or keep pressing forward one of those
habits is strengthened the more times we
choose to push on the stronger that
habit will become
it takes time and purposeful effort for
these habits to become ingrained but
once a person develops them in the gym
doing something as simple as choosing to
keep rowing hard for another minute they
can apply what they have learned to the
rest of their lives they will learn to
take the harder path so that they are
challenged more they will learn to put
extra effort into daily tasks who you
are depends entirely on your influences
and the level of effort that is put into
forging yourself into what you desire to
be
and that's awesome yeah I mean every
every decision you make either gets you
closer to your goal or moves you further
away and I'm not saying I never make the
decisions that movie to the left movie
further away I'm human just like
everybody else
yeah yeah definitely you know you know
you know we were hanging out yesterday
and I was like I was busy I'm like yeah
man I gotta go so in that busyness you
know what I had for dinner last night
yeah Mari no I didn't have MREs that's
not happening no my entire dinner was a
leftover piece of a Caesar salad and a
giant mint chocolate chip milkshake I
actually said my wife was like make me
because I was working and I did you know
it's you can't stop and eat when you're
trying to work and so I just said can
you make me just a giant mint chocolate
chip milkshake now I didn't get closer
to my you know physical goals but I got
a lot of work done yeah I got an extra
for whatever twenty-eight minutes worth
of work though because I didn't stop to
eat in there yeah you gotta take the
wins with the losses I dig it it's all
just about you know making that it's
like you plot your progress on a graph
and you're gonna have it's long it's
gonna go up and it's gonna go down a
little bit that's gonna go up and it's
gonna go down so as long as that trend
is upward then you know you really have
nothing to worry about but if that thing
starts to level off and then it go the
other way then you need to ask yourself
some questions you need to give yourself
some honest answers yeah you know we had
a conversation not too long ago a guy
asked about jujitsu belts and said you
know I understand that you shouldn't
because in jujitsu it's like hey you
shouldn't just like go to get a belt you
go cuz you want to get better and you
want to learn and and he said you know I
understand that you shouldn't just do it
to get the belts but it's good to mark
your progress and figure your progress
out and I was and that's true and that's
what you're saying like yeah and I've
talked about that too you know I related
to shooting where when you when you
focus
on the target your vision gets blurry
and so you lose track of the long-term
the long-term goal or the long-range
target so that's why we focus on our
front sight cuz we can keep that little
thing that's right in front three feet
in front of us on our rifle you can keep
that in focus so that's what you focus
on and every once in a while if you
start that maybe that gets a little
blurry well then you look at your
long-term targeting because that daily
grind will beat you down - yeah and if
you just give to the daily grind the
daily grind the daily grind beating you
down and then you you you forget what
your goal was in the first place but so
every once in a while yeah you got to
look up at your long-term goal and say I
want to be doing this or achieve that or
whatever I want to do 31 marathons see
well some people would have picked like
February right we'll do 28 you're going
to the full 31 that's the difference
right there yeah if I want to make it if
I want to make these points that's why I
rode my bike from Maine to Southern
California I was sitting there going
yeah I could I could ride Florida to San
Diego it would be technically be all the
way across yeah but technically but
there would be that but I don't want any
buts associated with anything that I do
I don't want anybody to have any reason
to say oh yeah Rob Jones he ran 31
marathons in 31 days you got to do a
good job on on your social media when
you're when you go out on this thing you
got to document this thing and post it
so yeah looking like I'm hoping so I'm
working with Sports Illustrated I think
they're gonna do a video nice I heard of
them yeah discriminating judge of videos
so yeah I plan like you know I
documented the bike ride that's the
documentaries on my website too yeah so
yeah I do try and document these things
and just in case people don't happen to
catch it while I'm doing it they can go
back and and use that as their example
for for what I've done they can find out
that way yeah well I know you get stuff
done and you hammer out your daily tasks
we're gonna let Ecco hammer out his
daily tasks right now technically we
time we tasks I do I extra respect on
the weightlifting analogy I think like
weightlifting and exercising in general
like Crick is like the perfect analogy
for those things you know oh yeah
because it's like yeah I mean I could go
into it but yeah that is an app an
outstanding analogy yeah like hey that
waits on you yeah you're either gonna
use it to get better or you're gonna let
it bury you in the ground yeah the
choice is yours what are you gonna do
yeah and like and it goes to show we
talk about this sometimes where you can
take a let's say a random person right
and be like hey let's go to the gym and
there can be literally opposite
reactions if you get to different people
so one guy can be like hell yeah let's
go to the gym yeah I'm gonna work out
and get sure I need to get in shape good
you know it's this thing or you can get
so many like that's the worst thing in
the world I don't want to go to the gym
I don't yeah like that's hard and it
hurts even the next day it hurts you
know so meanwhile it's the same exact
activity by the way you know so you can
look at in those two different ways you
know what else is messed up is there's
activities that are also good for you
and move you in a direction that you
want to be moving but maybe like let's
say the god you can let we can give you
a real good example you take a meathead
right and you go okay you want to go to
the gym what does the meathead say hills
yes let's go get it but then you say to
that same guy who seems all motivated
and fired up to improve himself yeah and
you say hey let's go read a book and try
and you know understand better this
concept of whatever yeah but what did
they say then so it's interesting
yeah the weight the weight isn't
necessarily just a physical weight right
it's pressing up against whatever it is
that's going to improve you
you can either use it to beat you down
or you can use it to make yourself
better yeah
and again just as the concept right
I think the exercise in weightlifting
and like your body just kind of
figuratively can demonstrate just so
much you know that a place and you
especially feel that way about curls is
that what I'm hearing anyway speaking of
curls wait should I go into this now
your daily tasks yeah yeah we should
yeah well I got Rob Jones here to listen
what up I can't wait to hear the support
the support yeah Lyle you get to witness
the support slide honor
so watch watch echo do his work his
life's work this life's worth right here
a support ship oh ha after this we can
go to my house he wants to be edited
video you know anyway made in America or
gin that's the company or gin main calm
you started in Maine yes I created
Krusty
yeah that's where this place is we just
got back what last week yeah we can have
whatever yeah that's a cool spot you
know he has a side note he is like this
I think it's on like the History Channel
or something like that where it was kind
of like a show and you know the story he
told about getting he got this the loom
right where he goes didn't actually make
right they they like came and filmed
some stuff
yeah and produce it yeah he showed it to
me but because when he's telling the
story I'm like man that took it took
like 2 8 hours or something or more
there's no more than that yeah I like to
get it and it's this big thing and it
kind of showed it they were there for
that yeah there's also moving the looms
ya know the Loomis no okay that and me
neither and then he asked me you think
you know what a lumen sounds like loom
I've heard that like was really rude of
the loom
right yeah and when you think about it
it makes sense because through the loom
is like right it's the fabric you know
it has all the strings yeah anyway so
when they say made in America in this
case it's for real made in America they
get to cotton from America they make it
with a loom yeah
with lien Americans that this guy Pete
Roberts up in origin which we're in
league now with origin yeah but if we
went up into old mills because all the
mills up there a lot of them shut down
and actually I think all of them shut
down and these were these were these
were factories that were like half a
million square feet and they were filled
with looms and filled with production
and filled with a war American workers
and it all went overseas and he went in
and literally bought a loom for like I
think that I think was like three
thousand dollars the cost of the scrap
metal that it was worth yeah anyways
took it hired some old-timers that knew
still know how to work it brought them
back to work and then started making
clothes and well making jiu-jitsu is
what he started with but but we're you
know got everything being lined up to
get made and that loom they only had
that one because they were gonna put in
a museum yeah yeah they were literally
gonna take that that one loom that they
had left never to put make it a museum
yes that's so awesome because you see
there are so many people out there now
they're like oh
our country has too many problems our
country has too many problems we need to
do this when you do that and or they say
somebody you don't do this somebody
needs yeah yeah and it's like hey you
don't you and here's a guy that's doing
that yeah yeah yeah and it's interesting
too when we went there you can tell he's
into it he's like he driving up there
he's talking about how yarn is on me
he's like yeah I got I gotta calm down
because I'm getting to the things you
don't know I need to say he's into it
because he went out and bought a broken
rusty loom and refurbished it and moved
it into a factory that he built on his
own property it's ridiculous yeah and I
chose to like the keys um like you might
do jujitsu right today yeah these are
like they're cool you know martial arts
keys or whatever but he brings like this
added like element to it well
specifically designs in fur yeah four
digits yeah it's not the kind where it's
like hey let me get Aggie Blanc from
overseas or whatever and yeah like
embroider my logo on it so it's kind of
like the same thing you don't you
have much innovation freedom with a
physical product he does though so it's
like I took I was rolling the other day
I take off the top and you'd left with
just the pants so the pants are like
they're by um like sizes you know you
were 36 yes in regular stuff is just
like numbers a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 6 this
is like fitted to you right so I'm
wearing the pants and they feel it kind
of like normal pants you know and I was
Greg in one there like they were
noticing us don't mind getting choked
out by everything my streak every day
and I wear it every day up to two tops I
wear it every day and the streak is
still alive every single time someone
asks like what up with that key let me
see let me see
nope way that fabric is woven is legit
yeah this legit yeah and see these short
sale right now I should I kinda in a way
shouldn't mention these cuz beats like I
know we're not making those choices make
these short we will make okay I've worn
these three days in a row by the way oh
that's what that smell was but yeah
they're made out of the same material is
one of the one of the keys it was nice
yeah I spilled some eggs on it and you
know it leaves them these shorts are
black but uh huh so you know you when
you spill eggs or out of nos feeding my
son yogurt and stuff and it's built on
it uh-huh
so you just take a brush like you know
like a brush you find under your sink or
whatever put some water knife scrubbed
it you can't do that on like your shorts
cattle start to wear it out you know but
Aggie is tough it's supposed to be tough
ya did it anyway sorry you can't get the
shorts I don't care I've been fired up
we'll make it we'll make them yeah so
stand by for that nonetheless jujitsu
keys all kinds our rash guards and even
like like regular clothes shirts hoodies
and whatnot the joggers keep putting on
the joggers and walking around in front
of my wife she likes that was a weird
thing because I didn't actually know
what do you know what joggers are there
new joggers you know they're like
they're they're like they're like
sweatpants but they're somehow more
high-end
yeah the sheet is different they kind of
taper down your leg like
you know I like skinny jeans skinny
jeans neither did I but I put them on
and I was like I was like these I don't
know how I look because I didn't have a
mirror in the cabin mmm except in the
bathroom but nonetheless um so I
couldn't see how they look they look
kind of strange from up here but I don't
know there's no he were the origin
jogger pants and the matching or City
sweatshirt or hoodie and he when he
rolled out like that like it was like it
was the deal he was a straight-up
Leisure Suit is what it is role not
playing around and then when I when it
came in
I thought people would be like oh you
know you don't match in that because I'm
not used to wearing but be fit I thought
I looked good in it and then my wife
said I look good in it oh that one but
what I'm for yeah made it of course it
was a moment of honesty because he
mentioned either you I don't I think he
was you or someone he was like I don't
think just jock who could pull it off
yes he's right like that no might have
been someone else I don't think it's not
like he's right either way no maybe I'm
not secure in my manhood no I just
thought very girls clothes
absolutely not nonetheless functionally
that is what I notice right when I put
them on though like when you roll out
you know how like if you have and not
that it's even a big deal even me
talking about that go says things like
you know how it is when like something
happens but actually no idea what he's
talking about but I roll with it because
we're trying to condense the timeline of
the supports speed speaking which is art
in the spirit of accuracy I'm gonna go
down this hole you know when you we're
having everyone sweatpants ever in your
life not really kind of sweatpants okay
Rob jumps I have warrants what
pre-injury I have yeah so consider this
when you let's say like I don't know
you're running or walk you know whatever
you like the slip answer you loose a
flow it's not a big deal I dig it
understand but the skinny jeans
sweatpants joggers we should really
skinny jeans off my podcast now you
reach it they function because they
don't flap her out there like if you're
running away though they work
I'm just running shorts right for that
very reason cameras three feet of snow I
just run sure you're pretty good to go
don't knock it till you try it also
chocolate some supplements don't know if
you knew this Rob Jones but super krill
available now available boom or denying
calm origin labs it says you call it the
top menu in the website labs super krill
joint warfare yes that's a big one I
mean we know krill is like the base yeah
the joint warfare yeah so good and the
significance well layers if you will I
think you know maybe that's the stretch
with layers but this is the the stuff
that you've been taking from yes jump
yes with some bonus bonus bonus stuff
that I now can take in one shot so like
when you're even before this podcast and
stuff you're like taking I mean krill
oil and all this stuff and you're like
you know would be make this even better
it's like you know those little elements
or whatever in one day you know I'm
gonna make my own and boom it happened
kind of happened yeah yeah so we're in
it
joint warfare that's a good one super
krill just crit has the added thing
right in the crits upper krill oil and
it's like super krill yeah that's super
krill dope girl okay what's gonna add
it's already super duper we could add
duper that'll be super duper girl see
now he's gonna take the market from us
Rob Jones super duper krill oil well it
does make a website but yeah so
basically everything you need for the
joint situation you're covered and then
what about that pre-work pre mission
mission premiers coming pre-workout it's
coming not available yet prana will be
coming yeah it's we're not going to talk
about that one well we are it is it is
in the testing phase and has been being
tested and legit it's so far so good
boom I'm kind of addicted to it yep also
on it dot-com / Jocko okay so I get all
my kettlebells firm on it I got into
kettlebells after this podcast kind of
started and you know on it has awesome
stuff specifically the kettlebells
because they're the designer ones you
seen that guy yeah yeah so I get the
whole set well I don't have the whole
set technically I have the weights that
I think I'm gonna be able to use what's
your heaviest one you haveno 40
kilograms that's cool man good story I
got the 90 pound one so whatever so
basically all 88 pounds that you have I
have that plus more so no big deal stand
there you go good and what you are
skinny jeans joggers contemporary
joggers from time backs at least four
pounds functionally it adds it by the
way got the gorilla ones a few weeks ago
the 90 pound one is the Bigfoot just for
information over are they ever gonna
make a hundred pound Jocko head actually
they said that people have been saying
there's been some requests ya know if
anyone would actually want that yeah I
saw a guy sent me a - it was a 250 200
something pound kettlebell dang I don't
even know what I mean
yeah I guess write goals legit there's
like you know some people are just
mutant strong yeah yeah one of my team
guy buddies just mute and strong ain't
trained jujitsu great dude but he got
the beast I don't know who makes it but
there's a kettlebell called the Beast
I think it's like a hundred and two
pounds or something but there was like
this little test
the Beast and he got the kettlebell out
of the box did the test past it I was
like I mean things that I couldn't do at
all yeah I was like okay um you're legit
yeah actually it's cool that's like one
of those exercises that you if you learn
that the form it's like they added
element cuz you got to learn the forms
yeah man the strength and those and
learning the form is good for you
because you're developing you're
developing neuro right muscular
connection yes it boom thank you you
know I was lost for words and you've had
me cover and move but yes it's basically
you have to learn to balance something
that's not balanced you know it's good
like that bag I lifted in Maine those
guys it yeah that's good
two hundred pounds by the way you know a
super already feel the first time also
they got what jump ropes maces you know
you if your workout gets boring
chocolate another problem we know we
know cuz you just win and all this stuff
but some people they get bored you know
where the workout get all this cool
stuff anyway on it calm slash chocolate
so good on also when you buy these
action put a link to your journal if you
don't mind yeah yeah there's nothing to
buy it's free yeah yeah yeah but if you
know you go on there I'll put it in the
book section and I'll be awesome if yeah
it's good and if you if people want to
get some of the other books that chuckle
uh talks about you go to our website
podcast calm books from podcast that's
on the top menu and then you click
through there to get your books takes
you to Amazon boom click through there
or if you do any other shopping but um
click through that's good way to support
small action big reaction it is a legit
way to support for sure it is I've been
I got asked that two times now yeah once
in Maine and I think I was at an event
the other day and someone asked me he
does it really helped I was like yes it
is yeah it's it I said it's exactly what
echo says it is you know small actually
it takes what like three extra seconds
small action boom one two clicks
whatever and you know big support big
reaction also subscribe to the podcast
if you haven't already and I'll seem
just kind of obvious right I do not
subscribe but if you haven't subscribed
or stitcher or Google Play yeah anything
that provides platforms just subscribe
man good way to support easy you know
boom also YouTube channel we have a
youtube channel i put was the last video
i put on there the book video oh yeah
its freedom you manual I thought it was
pretty good too yeah
I felt jock would get all the work
really lifting that was a hard night - I
mean you're lifting after like a whole
day I was like Brahman yeah was it
that's right that was like a long day
long day where I'm like okay just need
like these shots you know cuz we're
doing it for like other stuff and I'm
gonna grab the steals and whatever and I
was like I just need the shots what I'll
do is I'll make it here so you don't
have to put on all that weight and he's
like nah feel like the same exact thing
I was a shooting a video doing lifting
weights and they're like yeah we're just
gonna do with no way I'm like no but the
video that I want the weight that I want
to be on there is 135 pounds I want that
to be on video I don't want no weight to
be on video yeah he even went one
further that there was a few shots that
I was getting that didn't show how much
weight it just showed that front of the
you know is like an angle you could
kinda see part of the way kind of he's
like no it's like he wouldn't allow him
well I actually said you know I I took
the Rob Jones approach I was like okay I
got to move some weight around I'm gonna
use the opportunity to make myself
better and I dig it
but yeah nonetheless back to YouTube
boom we put some videos on there
including but not limited to the video
version of this podcast also additional
videos excerpts you know and various
other video deleted scenes if you a lot
of times we talk rubbish before we
actually
include you know or we don't include in
the podcast so sometimes we'll cut that
up and put it on there leave to add it
entertainment you know here chuckles
swear a lot you know he doesn't swear
that much on the on on the record but
you know he gets after it from time to
time
although if I'm hanging out with like
one of my bros yeah you know well yeah
yeah you don't effing just effing get
nuts with effing squats in your effing
Bing he was like yeah he like overdid it
nonetheless yeah YouTube that's a good
one
also Jaco as a store if you didn't
already know
guess what it's called coaster calm
without some t-shirts on there they're
cool they're cool you know some layers
on those t-shirts layers meaning not
physical layers we call poetic layers in
Ho etic now that's really reaching yeah
it's reaching a lot thanks good it's
pretty poetic you know what the layers
are with that though right
if you look at the good shirt it has jaw
closed head yeah that's good
right but the good is backwards and
here's the thing that's why when people
try to counterfeit that one they don't
they don't get the layers they just see
chocolate that's a marketing thing or
whatever yeah and let's sell that but
they don't get it they don't know the
layers so the good is backwards and
backwards for a reason they write it in
the mirror cuz who are you saying that
when you hear that who are you saying
that to you're not saying you know to
your poor daughter who's crying cuz she
skinned her knee
you don't say good she's like oh she
cries more that's not her man it's not
your missus message to give somebody
else your message to give to you like
that in your daughter cry in the first
place well she's you know I'm
cultivating her sensitive sight that's
all you're not wearing a t-shirt for
yourself to look down like that we're in
it so other people can read it you can
read it in a typical case but not these
t-shirts that t-shirt is for you great
up for you with the message with
chocolate face apparently that's for you
to not for everybody but this is for you
nonetheless that's just an example of
the layers
on the shirts chuckles dark comm is also
some hoodies on there some travel mugs
bumper bumper stickers the jucco 2016 I
took it off girl yeah we lost that
election yeah you did sorry I got like
27 votes yeah I got some legit votes
people posted them on Twitter some
people wrote me in straight-up they
wrote me in I said you know what I don't
want Hillary Clinton
I don't want Donald Trump I want jock oh
yeah I think it might have been a good
choice actually yeah I think I think it
might have been a good choice yeah
someone actually told me that I should
run for vice president that wouldn't
have been a good choice yeah I don't
know if you would have got my vote
nonetheless there's some cool stuff on
choco store that's the point you know
I'm not saying go buy some stuff I'm
saying go on there see what up see
what's on there and if you like
something get something good way to
support also there's a little thing
called psychological warfare you've
heard it yeah it's pretty don't have it
I'll tell you what all day okay so I
don't have to let you know that it's an
album with tracks choco tracks so
basically if you don't already know Rob
Jones news junkie knows I know obviously
let's say you're on your campaign
against weakness that's that's the
official going turn
campaign against weakness right and I'm
gonna be disciplined in all these areas
on my life waking up early diet I'm
gonna work out you know however many
times a day study study get smarter work
harder yeah just normal yes
normal getting after you cam down
campaign yeah and you have a moment of
weakness like Jaco with the mint
chocolate chip ice cream avoid that jock
obviously didn't listen to his own album
with tracks just for tracks of
psychological warfare what you do is any
time you you come across these moments
of weakness listen put a trap put a
track in like if you're having a hard
time waking up you wanna hit the snooze
whatever boom get wake up get up wake up
wake up wake up and get after it that's
the track name help you right through
that weakness
smash the weakness out actually oh yeah
psychological warfare chuckling mp3
iTunes
wherever Emma's mp3s are being
distributed that's where you can get
them uh you can also on Amazon you can
get something called Jocko white tea Rob
Jones had his first jock of white tea
today delicious not only delicious but
I've noticed you've been very attentive
your words are crisp and clear I mean
you feel the power right yeah
Lucas I totally look at him my mental
capacity increased at least tenfold yeah
if not more so there you go
chocolate white tea you can get that on
Amazon it did legit though how good does
it taste no it's really good yeah it's
it's and it doesn't it's it doesn't
really taste like tea right it's kinda
tastes like tea does have any sugar in
it no you tell me
joggle white tea doesn't have any sugar
and tastes like it and it tastes that
good it tastes like victory
hey we got some books on Amazon and
wherever you want to buy books extreme
ownership combat lessen combat
leadership lessons learned and how you
can apply those to business and life way
of the war your kid yeah way the warrior
kid that's what you need to get for
every kid you know it is so helpful for
kids I wish I had that book when I was 9
years old 10 years old 11 years old it
is so helpful and I'm getting such great
feedback so buy that for the kids you
know for sure coming up soon the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that's right it is a Field Manual how to
implement and execute operation
discipline into your life follow the
Field Manual you can get it from your
local bookstore you can get it from
Barnes & Noble you can get it from
Amazon let them all know what's up
also echelon front leadership consulting
for your business or team that's what we
do you can email us at info at echelon
front comm and in the meantime if you
need us or you just want to check in we
are rolling kinda deep on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and face sheet
ball hockey Rob Jones is at Rob Jones
journey at Rob Jones journey he's gonna
be documenting all this awesome slash
could be stupid but could be mostly
awesome stuff that he's doing and we
like to watch people do crazy stuff so
yeah we're gonna watch you do that and
I'll post a picture and usually I like
to put a little snippet of wisdom in
there a little paragraph for people to
read nice today so the New York Times
yeah don't go straight to the to the Rob
Jones snippet of wisdom I like the
example you say you want to be the
example because some people they said I
just want to be the exempt but they
don't explain it you just explained it
actually in a way that was kind of
revealing to me where it makes sense you
know you're like hey I'm gonna and this
goes for everything by the way like if
you want to I do like a special effect
sometimes like man I want to do this but
man that's like some high in a fact
can't do it on this and then but then
let's say look it up on YouTube and be
like oh wait look he did it right here
and then you know sometimes I show my
show how sometimes they don't but like
how you said like if you don't think
like if you think oh yeah that kind of
can't be done you know like for someone
in my position or whatever you know but
then you see someone he's doing it and
then you're doing it where it's like
you're doing even more so it's like uh
you're kind of reaching more people in
that way cuz still you're doing these
crazy things maybe one maybe two other
people yeah I can do that too but most
people they'll be like easy stuff but I
can do all this other stuff you know I
mean if stuff that they didn't think
they could do before that's so good
that's the words crazy not stupid the
stuff you're doing is awesome yeah it's
crazy
gotta be crazy to do it
so yeah Rob Jones journey and that
includes Rob Jones journey calm as well
which and that from there you can get to
the donation page for when you're
starting all this all this thirty-one
marathons in 31 days most people run a
marathon at any I think I've read it
takes like six months to actually
recover from a marathon yeah I guess it
depends on your level of preparedness
but yeah try to do it about six hours
that is awesome echo is at Echo Charles
in I am at Jocko willing echo you got
anything else for today thank you for
coming on Rob Jones Rob any closing
thoughts from you oh I just want to
start by pointing out that I think every
guest you've ever had on this podcast is
somebody that I consider to be a hero on
Idol I don't throw that around they're
Patriots and they are heroes and it is
humbling for me to be included for you
to have me on the podcast is vastly
humbling for me to be included among the
people that you deem worthy of being on
the podcast so I just want to thank both
of you for for having me and giving me
this opportunity and I just hope that
some of the stuff that I said can
resonate with with some of the some of
the listeners and beyond that I've done
a lot of stuff but nobody does that by
themselves I have had so many people
that have helped me therapists
prosthetists coaches mentors and family
friends and then especially Pam I mean I
told you before she's doing everything
she was instrumental in getting this
podcast done getting me on us as a guest
here took it upon herself to to tweet
you
she's callin pressed she's helping me
get venues she's been incredible and
she's my number one Supporter and you
know too good for me but hopefully she
doesn't listen to that hopefully still
she'll continue to be deluded but yeah I
mean I I'm at the top of the pyramid
like I get all the kind of the notoriety
and the congratulations for doing the
stuff that I've done but without the
base of the pyramid the pyramid is shit
just a block on the ground so without
all these people I mean I wouldn't have
accomplished it I would I might have
tried but I wouldn't be I wouldn't be
where I am probably would be on the
podcast I wouldn't have to actually done
anything well you know for everyone
that's come on and and then to sit here
and have you you know that to have you
and the people that have come on this
podcast and have you sitting across the
table from me and be able to spend time
with you yesterday and hang out with you
I am rewarded a thousand fold a thousand
fold from you to me that's that's where
the reward comes and it's an honor a
thousand fold for you to be here and and
be sitting here talking to me and I
thank you for coming on I thank you for
your service I thank you for your
sacrifice I thank you for the example
that you're setting which is awesome and
and showing everyone what it really
means to to persevere and to not only
not only overcome challenges but you are
embracing those challenges and turning
the harshest of challenges into
something positive and something good
and that is what I'm thanking you for
for explaining
what it really means to adapt and
overcome no matter what we face and
everyone out there that's listening and
you're going through hard times or
you're facing a rough patch or a
challenge or an obstacle in your life
adapt to it grow from it overcome it
transcend it and use the weight of that
challenge to make you stronger until
next time this is Rob Jones and echo and
Jocko out